Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code named Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy from men.
Shazamm bitches,
Jamie kill scenes in the house.
And we don't even,
we don't start this thing and experience.
So we get the music going.
I Dunno why
now it feels like a show.
I
don't know why it's a little weak ass psychologic.
I circled trick from my bitch ass mind.
If you hear a slight hum in the background,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's the issue for starting this so late on Ustream.
There's something going on with our mixer.
So we've got to get a new mixer.
So Brian has a duct tape this pitch together for this podcast and we're going
to,
um,
Jamie Kilstein knows about all this shit,
man.
This is the trials and tribulations of running a podcast.
He runs a citizen radio and James a standup comic and he's also a mixed martial
arts fanatic.
Loves the fights and just an all around.
Good Dude.
Thanks buddy.
You're,
you are defined by your diet.
However,
I don't know how that happened.
You're a Vegan man.
It's a tricky thing to be.
I was saying the other day like it's uh,
what's crazy is like,
so I'm already like a niche of a niche of a niche fucking comic.
Right?
Right.
She tell everybody very left wing,
very political.
But I also like,
but then I get fucked with lefties because I'm a comic so it's like a language
issue or like I hate,
oh,
I think I'm furious at fucking Obama and the majority of the Democrats.
So like it's very hard to like our show,
but like we've managed to like carve out this cool niche audience.
But even with them,
the Vegan thing,
it's still like,
I can literally get up on stage and be like,
you know,
the wars and illegal occupation and my people will be like,
fuck the war.
Or I'll be like,
people use religion as the excuse to hate gays.
And they were like,
fuck religion.
And that'll be like,
sometimes I like to eat portabella mushrooms and they're like,
you pussy mother fucker.
Like fuck you.
And there's,
so I got booted a Democratic fundraiser for saying I'm a Vegan.
And it's like really?
It's like you fuckers
they booed or for your dietary choices.
That's an interesting,
it's the one dietary choice.
It has a strong message to it though.
Cause Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean I think that,
I think people automatically feel like you are judging them when you say you
don't do that.
Right?
Yeah.
Because there's no connotation.
I mean people,
they don't want to think about it.
I never,
when I used to eat a ton of meat and don't get me wrong,
the reason I'll never be able to be like preachy is because I will never be able
to make up for the amount of fucking spam I ate or like Taco Bell,
like my damage has been done.
I'm just trying to like repent for me at this point and like,
uh,
but uh,
there's a disassociation,
right?
So when you're eating the hamburger,
it's a hamburger.
It's a new word to you.
It was not a cow die the way it died.
When you uh,
make nugget,
like you don't think of it as like a little chicken or whatever.
And so I think when you say I'm a Vegan,
that's saying I don't need animals and that's automatically making the other
person think like,
well,
I don't want to fucking think about that.
Like no one wants to,
no one eats a burger.
Even your fucking tough like dudes who were just like,
yeah man,
I'll watch the video,
I'll torture myself.
It's like,
will you like you,
you can't even walk to the store to get pre made me to like,
you're not going to fucking go kill a boar with weapons unit.
You know what I mean?
Like no one wants to think about that.
They just want to eat it.
It looks fried.
It doesn't look like an animal.
It doesn't have a face.
And by you saying you don't do it,
I think that makes them think about it.
And that's a real hard time accepting that other people allowed to make
different choices other than them,
whether it's getting a fucking windows computer or whether it's,
you know,
going with at and t over Verizon,
people are fucking crazy.
I know.
And that's half of it.
Why would anybody give a fuck?
I do not like self righteous vegans.
I do not like people who are constantly in people's faces about,
you know,
cruelty to animals and I you,
you are absolutely correct for factory farming is a fucking atrocious bipap
product of civilization and the detachment from the natural world.
Again,
that sense Ted Nugent's got it.
Right.
Like if you want to eat meat motherfucker,
you should be out there with the fucking boat.
And I got like a bow and arrow.
Yeah.
Take that shit down yourself.
And that's the real experience when you buy something ramped up and some fucking
cellophane plastic thing at the supermarket and you need it,
that's,
there is a disconnect.
But the vegans that like give people shit,
they're just as country as the people who stand outside of abortion clinics.
I know what I'm saying.
She's anything.
Yes,
exactly.
Now that's it.
And like I know like your listeners can relate to,
especially the ones who are super into politics.
It's like when there is information that you have and you know the majority of
people don't have it,
you go create,
I mean there's part of me that starting to think those crazy fucking like
homeless people you see in New York,
they're like are waving a book around and like just screaming chip for all we
know.
They're the smart ones.
They're the ones that actually like finish the Chomsky book.
And I'm like,
why aren't you guys fucking paying attention to who gives a shit about the dead
baby and whatever her name is.
You know,
like seriously.
Like maybe they're the smarter ones.
Just people have just ignored him for years and they're like,
that's it.
I'm taking it to the bus.
Well they probably have some good points,
but I don't think those
always go against the guy living on the streets screaming at no one.
Okay,
look,
they've made some bad life to say this clearly.
But you're right,
man.
I mean,
you go deep into the fucking back of the Chomsky books and you do that for
years.
You could really lose your mind thinking that nothing you can do helps.
And that this,
this world is on a downward spiral that is unstoppable and uncontrollable.
And a lot of people would say the intelligent thing to do would be just to enjoy
the moment.
You know,
it was a great hunter s Thompson quote.
The light became a measurably better once I was forced to stop taking it
seriously.
And I tweeted it last week.
But really when we have to accept at some level that we are temporary organisms,
you,
you should have causes,
you should have ideas,
you should have,
you know,
points to the way you,
your philosophy works and the way you look at life.
But you've gotta be careful about wasting your whole life on that shit.
Yeah,
sure.
Man.
I mean,
the key is you can't use the,
that you can't use that negativity as an excuse to do nothing to be apathetic.
I mean,
we've had chops down or show like five times.
And at first we were joking around that even if you're,
that we were like,
you know,
what's your favorite thing to do?
Would be like cut myself while watching Al Jazeera.
Like,
I mean,
the dude's like,
he's not really the bearer of good news.
But we ended our interview,
we end our interviews by being like,
you know,
what makes you happy?
And he suddenly,
he just fucking lit up and he's like,
people marching in the street,
people holding truth to power.
You know,
people who are doing radio shows like this.
I mean,
like once you dig deep,
because here's the thing is like when I was a,
a teenager,
I was like,
just smart enough to give myself an excuse to do nothing.
You know what I mean?
It would be like,
why don't you vote?
Because both parties are the same.
Why don't you watch the news?
Because they're all owned by corporations.
Now,
both of those are fucking 100% true.
Uh,
but with that said,
you can run for office,
you can support a third party.
You can petition,
uh,
the Democrats to actually do what they say they're going to do for the news.
You can watch independent news.
You can watch Al Jazeera,
you can watch the BBC,
you can read out of country newspapers.
But I think a lot of people use all the conspiratorial shit to do nothing.
You know,
you have liberals who were sitting there and they're like,
man,
fuck the corporations,
and they have their Budweiser beer and they're Philip Morris,
cigarette factory,
farm stick.
They're like,
where are these corporations getting all the money?
No,
I'm not.
I'm down.
You know,
it's,
it's from you.
You got to actually like do something and not,
it's really fun to go to a bar and talk shit and then wake up and do nothing.
You know?
At a certain point though,
some people feel like there's nothing you can do.
You can try and you can,
you can dance in the street and you can march,
but things don't change.
A black guy gets an office and 30,000 more people get shipped off to
Afghanistan.
All the bombing continues and he wins the Nobel Peace Prize.
I'm still,
the bombing continues man,
drones and Pakistan and who knows what the fuck is going on and all sorts of
creepy corners of this world.
Right?
I mean,
how can you stand up for that bully are adorable because,
well,
it's because like we said,
Mac and windows and flooding,
the 18 teen Verizon,
I'm on team Democrat man now.
And you as a lefty have to be careful because you know,
if you start shitting on,
you know,
you start telling the truth,
and not having some team that you're on and you gotta say,
Hey man,
I've,
Obama is operating for corporations.
He's fucking us over.
He's fucking the whole picture over.
Yep.
And I mean we get more shit from,
I would rather a conservative comes straight at me and be like,
here's what I disagree with.
I think we can have a conversation.
Right.
What makes me more mad was he makes you feel crazy as the Obama people who just
can't admit when he does.
You know where it's just like,
hey,
why didn't he,
why didn't he get us universal healthcare,
like you said,
it's just like,
don't talk about him.
It's the worship.
The leadership.
Where's that universal healthcare.
Well,
he had to compromise on that because he was going to close Guantanamo open.
Now we didn't close Guantanamo.
I mean,
that's what,
that's the way it works.
If you don't have a billions of dollars,
you know,
it's really hard to get your voice heard.
I mean,
it's crazy and that's when I do understand people just wanting to do nothing or
just,
you know,
live off the land somewhere.
I will not believe that a guy like Ron Paul or Gary Johnson can get elected.
I do not believe know it works.
I do not believe it's real.
I believe you absolutely have to be playing in the game to get into that
position.
I don't think they'll ever let those guys win.
I don't think they'll ever let anybody win who wants to completely revamped this
entire corrupt,
fucked up pile of bullshit.
That's why local elections matters.
That is true though.
You know,
if that's true,
you local elections are what really counts your community,
your city,
for sure.
That that's real.
That's real politics,
Ron Paul too.
I mean,
even with that,
it's like it's one of those things where you want,
you want to,
you want to call yourself.
Most people who listen to your show,
I bet a lot of them call themselves libertarians.
I wanted to call myself a libertarian.
Why?
Because we see Democrats and Republicans and they're all kinds,
right,
but never tearing and you think great because you hear like legalized drugs in a
stay out of the bedroom in and then suddenly it's like get rid of all public
schools and you're like,
what the fuck was that?
And they're like,
no drugs.
We eat.
And you're like,
no,
go back to the school thing motherfucker.
And the problem is when you want,
when you want to prioritize everything.
What industries do we have from privatization?
You have,
you have companies like blackwater who were fucking over the troops.
You have the healthcare lobby or a lobby,
the pharmaceuticals.
Whenever you're doing something for factory farming,
whenever you're doing something for profit,
you're trying to do it as fast and as profitable as possible.
So people get fucked over in the end,
you know?
But our number one miss is the,
the education and this and the idea that you would make all education private
and make poor people not have access to and have to raise her own kids and put
their own kids through homeschooling year.
That's,
that's completely ridiculous.
Well,
that shit's happening right now.
I mean,
you look at all these budget cuts and you know,
people just forget.
People vote against their own interests all the time.
You know,
can I have to,
I've had some of the best conversations with conservatives either ever,
ever after a show.
Cause they'll come up to me and they'll say,
hey,
I didn't agree with you,
but you were funny.
And then I'll be like,
wait,
stop.
Like,
let's talk.
And then like,
what don't you agree with me on?
Right.
And the conversations usually goes something like this,
well I don't really care about gay people anymore.
That's more like an older generation.
Like they can fucking do whatever they want if a gay friend.
And it's like,
well what if like what if like a soldier comes back and he really needs like
assistant,
he's like,
oh my God,
what was holder comes back and he needs assistance.
The government should totally help him out.
And then I'm like,
all right,
so why are you Republican?
It's like my dad is.
And like if you just talk about it,
you can find fucking solutions.
You know,
I don't think that that person's going to go out and open like his own mom and
pop abortion shop.
Cause he liked the funny liberal comedian.
Uh,
but you start to see shit you agree on and you start to realize that you just
don't hear those middle ground solutions.
Uh,
on the news.
People think of Republican and Democrat.
It's very simple.
The characters are very clearly laid out.
There's a,
you know,
there's,
there's a fucking cowboy and an Indian.
It's real simple.
The Democrat is always like really loose and with,
with spending they want to overspend and community things.
They're very soft,
soft on crime,
soft on war.
So often defense and then Republicans are no nonsense.
People are Republicans or be bolded,
probably believe in God and don't want to,
you know,
don't want to deal with too many hippies in the yard and that's,
you would get them cylon party.
Yeah they get off my lawn party and I mean that's how we look at it in our
heads.
So when when when you get on one of those fucking teams and you just limit
yourself to that,
you know,
did that box that you're operating it,
it's a very weird thing that we like to do to be on these teams.
That is bizarre and wine.
I think that's why so many people like I think that's why the libertarian
things,
he'll pass.
You just need a label.
And even if you don't have any label,
you don't have a,
what do you say?
You proudly declare yourself an independent.
I'm above the fray and part of me wants to be like,
just pick a side and start losing friends like the rest of us mother fucker.
You know what I mean?
Station with a buddy of mine is a really brilliant guy.
He's a writer.
He's like,
well,
you know I'm a Democrat so I want us to win,
so get the fuck are you talking about man,
you want us to citizens the Dodgers?
That asshole doesn't have you in mind,
man.
Trust me.
He will send you off to war and you'll come back with no legs dark.
This is ridiculous.
I think the future's going to be like,
I'm on team anonymous or something like that.
Have you been listening to like what that that lately they're going to,
yeah,
that's crazy.
Those guys mean what they're doing with anonymous is doing is they are choosing
people that they think are cunts and they're going after him and they're not
doing it for profit.
They're doing it and they're doing it on their own and they're doing it in
anonymously and they're eaten meeting an IRC channels and so far they've been
fucking successful.
At,
I mean there's this generation could possibly be generation of the hackers and
that would be pretty fucking bad ass.
It's very clear that there's a certain level of society that knows way more
about computers than the average versa.
I know these little crazy motherfuckers can't get into systems bad.
They could steal credit cards and all kinds of shit.
It's fascinating really.
I mean,
it's fascinating on one hand that there's these people that are so intertwined
in the operating systems and that they are able to make these back doors and
able to get into people's computers through emails.
Rupert's stepping down,
you know,
is he stepping down?
That's what I heard last is that he was stepping down because of the recent
hacking over,
you know,
he was on trial today.
I heard he got a pie in the face.
I didn't hear about the stepping down though.
No,
let me get,
how exactly is he implicated?
Did he know that they were,
if for people who don't know Rupert Murdoch's company,
his corporation is a news.
People over there were,
um,
apparently bugging people's phones and even possibly victims from September 11
and from the seven,
seven attacks in London.
And they were getting information from people talking on these just to break the
story.
And it was even more fucked up about that is sometimes cause they were running
out of memory,
they would,
uh,
they would delete messages.
Uh,
so certain people,
I've just lost our messenger.
There was one case where like,
ah,
when they,
because they heard it was just what this single murder in the UK because they
heard the message deleted.
They thought that she was still alive and she raised,
she was deleting her messages.
She was still alive when she was fucking dead.
Oh my God.
But you know,
the story that's not really being talked about is Rupert Murdoch lost a really
gigantic bid,
uh,
for
a big station at the BBC.
That would've given him like pretty much the most media in the UK show much
media in fact,
that it would be illegal to own that much media in other countries.
Right.
And this is the problem.
Even if you are right wing,
even if you do watch Fox News,
at no point do you want one dude owning so much of the information you get.
You remember it's books,
TV,
newspapers,
magazines that you're just getting,
you know,
you turn on Fox News,
you read the Wall Street Journal coming from the same people,
right?
And it goes overseas and he was bigger and bigger and bigger and that's what you
don't want.
Do you want to be able to get your news sources from as many places as possible
so you can compare and find
out who's full of shit,
really amazing that someone has such a bad motherfucker then they could rocket
like that in 2011 now.
I mean,
it's really incredible that a Rupert Murdoch can still exist.
we're not in the age of William Randolph Hearst where he really had his own
paper manufacturing companies and he,
his own paper mills and he actually grew forest,
grew the paper,
cut the paper,
sent the paper out,
printed whatever the fuck he wanted on it and sent it out for sure.
I mean,
this happens all the time.
it happens with lobbyists and politicians.
As you see,
the lobbyists are writing half of the laws.
They're just giving them to the politicians.
You know what I mean?
You talked about that last week with Brian Calendar.
It was a good buddy of mine who's a very well versed and the political system.
When we got deep into the whole idea of lobbyists,
it's fucking criminal.
It should be completely against the law,
especially the,
you know,
they'll,
they'll sign a bill that favors Comcast and suddenly they quit and they're
working for Comcast.
Yeah.
It's like,
how is that?
That's like cartoonishly evil,
you know what I mean?
Did you see the,
um,
uh,
the movie on the financial crisis?
Um,
uh,
I know what you're talking about inside job now and actually I heard it
fascinating.
It's so good,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's fucking incredible.
But it's,
it's really heartbreaking too.
And one of the things that's in it is how many of these professors of economics
at big universities eventually wind up getting big jobs,
working,
working for companies,
and they get fucking multimillion dollar paid it.
I mean,
it's,
it's really simple.
Why they choose to allow certain things that they allowed.
I mean they,
they decided that systematically they were gonna make the,
all these porous holes in the economy that they could exploit.
The,
the,
the good news is the Internet.
I mean we were talking before about like not only generation of,
of uh,
of the hackers,
so like that's bad ass and I think all of us got our kind of like Jason Bourne
fantasies were like,
awesome.
Uh,
but it's also like shows like that.
Like you don't,
the flashlight's not going to call you and be like,
oh,
you were talking a little bit too much about these lobbyists jail.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Why don't you take it fucking easy on the bankers?
Like they're not going to do it.
We don't have any fucking sponsors where we can say whatever we want.
These,
the blogs are starting to take over the newspapers.
Why?
Because people like computers more.
No,
because the newspapers fucked us and the newspapers started doing,
you know,
the New York Times,
which is known as like the big liberal rag.
They essentially get memos from the white.
They have to get permission from the White House to,
to,
to print the stories with the Jordan.
That's the reason the wiretapping story.
It took two to three years on the Bush administration was like,
can you sit on that?
And they were like,
all right.
And,
and that's,
that's our intrepid journalists today.
That's the liberal New York Times.
They just fucking sat on it for Bush.
Yeah.
And then they broke it and they were called treasonous or whatever.
And it's like,
that's your job.
Your job as a journalist,
isn't it?
Tried to get invited isn't to try to beat fucking chuck Todd at these White
House parties were just drinking the wine and reporting on the White House soup
of the day.
That's for just pussy cunt.
That's all you are.
Phone boots up and there's a picture of you next to Obama.
All it is just,
yeah,
just the leaning in like a,
that's all it is,
man.
And these people are just fucking mouthpieces for war criminals.
That's what you do now.
You're,
you're just a fucking year an actor.
You're not doing anything original,
you're just a page or given lies and you fucking read those lines.
But if it is true that a guy like Ron Paul will never be allowed to slip through
the system if they can rig the machines like it was proven they did during the
Bush administration with the Diebold system,
which eventually they had to change their name,
but there's a bunch of moves hacking democracy's a great documentary on it where
you can watch now has burnt off absolutely 100% proven that it was designed to
be altered by a third source.
It was designed so that you could rig voting like,
and no one went to jail for that.
You know what I'm saying?
But if that's true,
if we,
if we agree on this,
that a guy like Ron Paul's never going to get through a guy who is going to
radically change the system is never gonna be able to get through.
What is this then?
This is not really democracy.
This is horse shit.
This is an imperial lakes and imperialist nation.
This is the,
they're,
they're an empire.
I mean,
it's a corporate empty empire now,
right?
You're 100% rights.
So that gives you an excuse to be like,
oh,
okay,
well let's just fucking get high and suicide pact that,
but the good news is what you can do besides getting the information out on the
Internet.
I don't hunt for resources.
Uh,
would,
you can also do is you just,
you have to be really loud because if someone like Ron Paul or Ralph Nader,
who by the way agree on a ton,
uh,
if someone like them,
if they get into the debates,
if they get petitioning enough,
if people are loud enough and not like,
oh,
well marching is fucking stupid.
Like if they're loud enough and they can get someone like that in the debates,
what that does is that steers the conversation.
Right?
And it makes that,
cause they're gonna happen with Obama once he got out of the primaries,
it's just him and McCain.
So is he going to pander to the left or is it gonna Pander to the right?
Clearly he's going to pander to the right.
If you still have someone like Ralph Nader or Ron Paul in there as well,
pushing back and they actually see that as a threat instead of just this blind
warship to Obama,
they see a third candidate has as a threat.
They're going to need to start pandering towards Ron Paul's direction.
They're going to start to need to start pandering towards,
uh,
Ralph Nader's direction.
I mean,
the bottom line is,
even if you're rigging voting,
what percentage of America votes?
I mean,
it's pathetic,
right?
You have to inspire all these young kids who were at home getting high,
but don't vote that you want to get high fucking on your front lawn.
You have to go out and do something.
You have to actually go out and vote or be loud.
And that's why it only think that example.
It only changes on the state level.
I mean,
that's what the United States of America supposed to be.
It's supposed to be about local government.
It's only supposed to band together in times of war,
right?
I mean the idea of medical marijuana,
they did change it in California and then the federal government can override
it.
Exactly.
And that's where it gets creepy.
Yeah.
That's where it gets really fun.
That's where it gets imperialist.
That's where it gets the,
you're in an empire.
You're,
there's a bunch of people who arbitrarily decide what you are not allowed to
vote on in your states.
And that's against the fucking constitution for sure.
Man.
That's against how this whole bizarre system of self government was ever
created.
It was created so that we could get away from all the bullshit that they were
doing in other countries in Europe.
And it's just chest thumping.
I mean,
look,
these politicians don't give a shit about pot.
They don't give a shit.
They do though because pharmaceutical companies give a shit about,
cause it's very,
very damaging to their profit line.
But it's also more so just a tough guy thing.
Dude.
It could kill the pharmaceutical industry.
Like the MP three industry or the MP three creation killed the music industry.
It could marijuana.
If marijuana was legal,
would crush the pharmaceutical industry,
they would lose billions of dollars.
No question about it.
There's going to be a lot of shit that you still need for high blood pressure or
glaucoma or whatever the fuck it is.
Yeah.
There's something,
there's going to be useless for pharmaceutical companies,
but make no mistake,
let's take about it.
They're going to lose a giant chunk of the business that's like,
that's why it's illegal.
It's 100% just fucking jerk offs running around saying that they're trying to
protect people.
Meanwhile,
cigarettes are readily available everywhere.
The most insane 400,000 plus people in America,
5 million worldwide now directly die prematurely as a result of cigarette.
Can I also bring up that even more than that die from heart disease and cancer
and a leading cause of that is a bad diet.
Is it a leading cause that or is it being a fat fuck with a bad diet and then it
could be being a fat fuck with it that it's mostly being a fat fuck.
You know you can eat a lot of meat and be healthy as fuck.
You just have to need that shit and you have to burn it off.
I was a fucking end before I went vegan.
I was at fatty vegetarian and like well cause I was just like,
oh I mean healthy man because I'm not eating meat and I,
it was like macaroni and cheese and pizza and I was just like,
yeah I'll see you fuckers at the top.
We like Jamie has a bag of fucking food that he brings with him on a plane.
You're like pretty pretty dedicated to this and packed up and like little bags
and do you have a little Tupperware?
It just says on it,
I'm better than you and there's a picture of a smiling.
Okay.
Do you will go out of your way to make sure that you get like a full spectrum of
amino acids?
So funny is like,
so once I went vegan instead of vegetarian,
I actually got healthier.
I started training more when I was just like a vegetarian.
Like,
I didn't really do much.
And when I ate meat I didn't do shit.
Um,
and I also smoked.
I also drank.
Uh,
and,
and then once I went Vegan,
that's when I actually started paying attention and stuff because you hear like,
oh,
are you gonna get your protein?
So you just start getting creative.
And I never knew what fucking chemo was,
or Kale.
I never had more developed mushrooms.
And so I actually ended up eating much healthier,
wants to start thinking about my diet.
And I was like,
I train like six days a week now.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
and,
and you look at the,
the UFC file,
by the way,
I don't get,
especially cause you always bring it up.
I get so nervous.
I never knew I was such an Errand Simpson fan until I found out he was a Vegan
and I was like,
you better fucking wind now.
Or every asshole on the underground.
You gotta you cow.
And uh,
yeah man.
I think it's really cool that like these really great fighters like Erin and
Fitch and you know,
uh,
or did it just for performance reasons.
I don't know about um,
Erin Simpson,
but the real issue with it,
it was actually ethical too,
which happened.
You never seen him act.
Dan's like is a big proponent.
Diane Zinc is a brilliant guy and he's really smart.
He's a brilliant photographer as well.
Somebody just posted some of his stuff on the underground and I was watching it
yesterday.
Yeah,
man.
Looking at through as a clips.
It was,
photography's a fucking amazing,
he's a fan of the podcast too.
I'd love to have him on.
We're going to have him on.
He's great.
One.
Aaron's really fucking interesting to your man.
Where like I started following him on
Twitter and like anyone being like a homophobe just calls the fuck out.
Yeah.
He seems like a really good day.
Very,
very friendly guy in real life too.
Yeah,
for sure.
What I'm saying is when you're,
when you're,
especially in training,
what it does is if you get all you,
if you get the full spectrum of amino acids into your body,
and I mean some people can't,
some people they feel like they just don't feel the same unless they have meat.
But you,
you can train all day long like that because it's so easy to break down.
Oh yeah.
And your recovery.
Yeah.
You can.
I recover a time like you're not digesting,
digesting food.
Like I fucking love meat.
All right.
I,
I love the shit out of some venison too.
I like,
I like animals that are fast and they get shot and then you eat them.
Those are the best ones.
I think the ones that run fast because you can taste the hope because they
almost got away.
No,
I think there's,
there's some,
some vibrance to them.
You know,
I think the reason why they run fast is because they're really nutritious.
It's fat slovenly animals and just kind of ponder wrong and you step up to them.
She put a shotgun in their mouth,
they didn't even budge and blow their fucking brains out like a cow and he did
something good for you.
I think the animal that hears you and his ears are twitching,
there's a prize in his flesh,
you know,
that's an animal that's,
it's hard to get.
And I think evolution makes things that are difficult to get oftentimes worth
getting.
Like fish.
Fish are fantastic for you.
And one of the reasons why they're fantastic for us because they're really
fucking hard to get
I that you were saying and I think there's something to that.
I know.
Do you ever just fantasize though?
Like,
like,
Hey,
I,
you know,
I'm just going to have a little filet to down man.
I mean it's like a,
it's like,
it's like anything where it's like you just developed new cravings.
It's like when you quit smoking and after 10 years you start to feel sick around
smoking.
You know what I mean?
I call faggotry
really?
Cause you only retire the word,
but I can put like Qa things at it.
Yeah.
I can say faggy.
I can say faggotry I,
but I can't say fag.
I can't call somebody.
But faggotry is a type of behavior that is nothing,
nothing to do with homosexual.
My new fairwinds it's,
it's a bag in the,
any around here.
You're tired of this.
Well,
write me about it.
So here,
here's why I retired.
It is,
um,
you know,
I always,
I obviously only used the word,
uh,
when I was chasing the packet,
scared gay people.
No,
I only,
I only use the word like ironically,
like in the voice of the bad guy or whatever like that.
Or even if I was telling like a story,
which even that I don't like doing,
like if I was called it,
but it just happened plenty of times.
Everybody has is if you haven't been called a Faggot,
you're not living.
Right?
Yeah,
that's very true.
Taking some chances.
That's what it was called you a faggot at least once in your life.
What are you doing?
Doing everything perfect.
Buddha,
come on son.
So,
uh,
so what ended up happening was a,
ah,
so this is,
this prevents us fault.
So it ended up happening was,
ah,
uh,
I'm still at my old bit.
I had this like old joke cause like,
I don't like the drug anymore,
but like,
it was like just making fun of,
uh,
like Texas state motto.
And it said like,
um,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
what the fuck has it,
what's their motto?
It's a like,
don't mess with Texas,
right.
Instead of the joker,
again,
this is one of the first year,
cause I wrote,
it was like,
you know,
that's the only state motto where with a motto is a threat.
And then I'm like,
if that's when they went with like,
imagine what they passed up on,
like,
and then it was just Texas,
you better back the fuck up faggot.
And there was like,
Hey,
he used the word.
And uh,
and what was so interesting was I'm like,
all right,
so I'm making fun of that.
Right?
You know,
that kind of,
and close on the fight,
right?
So then here's what happens.
So what happens is two things.
Number one,
I'm on stage,
uh,
at a shitty comedy club in New York and I'm bombing right?
It's just a bunch of people who were like super right wing,
they hate me.
So in my head I go,
not,
I'm going to do the Texas joke.
I go,
I'm going to get the Faggot joke right.
And this is like deep subconscious,
like when I'm like talking to don't really realize it did it til afterwards.
And sure enough,
I say the joke,
which is making fun of Texas,
right?
It's making fun of that mentality.
And they start laughing and they start laughing at the word.
They were laughing at the joke or the premise,
they just like that word.
And there is like as a comic,
I mean we can defend it all day by being like,
there's just a sound about the word and there is,
it's just that hard t at the end.
But then what happened was so much creepier is a,
is very nice woman who saw me in San Francisco.
Uh,
you know,
she tweets me and Facebook's meaning she's just a fan.
She emailed me one day and she goes,
uh,
you know,
my kid loves your CD and my kid listens to like you and Mitch Hedberg.
And I'm like,
that's pretty dope.
And like he's like,
he's young.
He's like,
he's like 11 or 10 or something.
And you know the first email was really nice that he's going to science camp and
he's like really scared.
Can you write him a little email?
And I was like yeah,
totally.
I was like oh I hope there's more smart kids like you.
And I wrote this little email and I'm like I'm a good guy.
And then a couple of months later,
right before the green room,
cause she was there and Paul for some reason wanted me to do that joke cause I
was not much round white and he wanted me to like Bash Texas or whatever.
He goes,
uh,
she writes me and she goes,
you know my son can't come but he wanted me to send you this.
Uh,
him and his friends love your CD so much that uh,
they did one of your bits and the second she said they did one of your beds,
my heart fucking just sank.
And I'm like,
I know exactly what bit did it this is,
and I plug in my headphones cause I don't want my wife to hear the uh,
hate speech that's about to come leaping out at my computer.
And I just see a line of 12 year old boys and girls,
all San Francisco.
So just like the widest most like fucking area and looking kids all in unison.
You pet her back the fuck up faggot.
And I just like jumped on my computer.
I'm like,
you fucking get them right now.
You explained to them like the irony that I don't say that word anymore,
they blah blah blah.
And it's like,
don't tell me that they don't think that word is now part of a,
you know,
an okay vernacular.
They're not going to start hate crimes but and you know,
right.
But they're 12 there 12 it would have been an awesome example if there's 30 year
olds and you change their minds,
but for 12 year olds,
yeah,
of course they're going to like react to that.
It's not for them.
The bits not for them.
Of course you believe that there's nothing wrong with that bit,
you know,
and for you to have that bit used in a way that is not what what you were,
that's like leaving a hammer around and someone throws it through a car window.
Sure.
No,
yeah,
it is ridiculous that,
you know,
you left the hammer around but,
but,
but it's not,
but it's supposed to be for everybody but a gay person's window.
Yeah.
And then it's sad.
Well,
you know my problem,
I had
an issue with it.
I called my dog a faggot and I called some ants,
a faggot and my spike TV special.
But it's not,
I don't mean he's gay.
It was a bit about the talking dog pod commercial.
My bit was like,
you know how mad you would be if you told your dog you loved him every day and
he didn't say shit until all the sudden he's like,
wish you wouldn't smoke pot.
You can fucking talk the whole time around.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean we never,
yeah.
I mean when I said it,
we never call.
I mean,
my wife one day I was like,
wait,
when we still worked like day job,
she was like,
uh,
today somehow,
I don't know how you did it,
but you manage to call a baby and the sky a faggot.
It's funny though,
like,
and yeah,
obviously there is no connotation,
but you know,
just like people who listen to your podcast,
just like,
uh,
you know,
fuck it.
And 12 year old kids,
it's like you just don't want to be the dude who throws it out there because
look,
I mean,
there were kids at 12 year old at 12 years old that know they're gay that were
tossed around.
I wish you could just throw it around in front of gay people and I wish they get
thrown around in front of you.
A lot.
Great word.
If you,
if you didn't have any hate in your heart.
Well,
and that's the problem a lot too.
I mean,
Alison and I,
when we first moved in together,
we had two gay roommates and like we used to throw the,
that was when that was at the,
at the peak of our use of the word.
But when I was explained the whole thing about the spike thing,
I was explained by a gay guy who was a,
an executive for a company that I will not name,
but he was a gay guy and he was telling me that I couldn't say it because it's
their word,
right?
He goes,
it's our word,
it's our nigger.
He really said it's our nigger where you just like,
you know,
you can't say that word because that's not yours.
I told him that that was the gay shit I've ever heard in my life.
Then he can go fuck himself and it's like,
it's a joke in my act about it,
but it really I,
that is exactly what happened,
man.
He literally said that and I literally said that like,
you can go for,
that's the gay shit I've ever heard.
Like that's ridiculous.
I can't have a word all of yourself and buy.
Why does everybody want to connect everything to nigger?
Why can't it just be a bad word?
Why does it have to be,
oh,
that's the Filipino nigger.
What the fuck?
Why does everybody have to do that?
Is it,
is it that ridiculous?
We can't figure it out any other way.
You have to say.
The only way I know it's bad is if you say it's your nigger.
Oh it's the,
that's what fag it is.
It's your nigger.
I didn't know know Louis C K has that really great bit about it too.
About the n word or just like you just made me think of the real word.
Right.
That's so funny.
Yeah,
it's true.
But it's tough.
It's really tough man.
Because it's like a lot of times like it's,
it's,
it's hard leaving comedy or irony in the hands of people who don't know how to
use it.
It's true.
You know what I mean?
And what always scared me.
Especially cause I talk about like gay rights a lot and like,
you know,
I'm filthy,
it's not like a prude thing.
I'm,
you know,
using cock sucker and stuff like that.
The only fear I would have is like,
I mean there are people that get legitimate like trigger kind of like almost
post traumatic check.
I mean if there was just a war,
if you just got the shit kicked out of every day for like your sexuality,
which at the time you're young enough not to even know if it's,
if,
if all the people were true,
if you really are broken,
if you're doing something wrong,
if you really should like women,
you know,
vice versa.
And that was just the word you heard and you got the shit beat out of you.
And then you hear someone who's like sticking up for you.
You know,
you're obviously pro gay rights,
you don't give a shit,
but then you just hear that word.
You still just get that kind of like,
ah,
I'm still,
he still didn't have my back,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
and that's just like a risk,
especially when like I've come up with so many grosser things to fucking say
when I'd just like,
all right,
don't use that word.
Just see something else you can do.
You can come up with just filth if you just aren't putting weird fucking word
combinations together and stuff like that.
It's more fun,
you know?
Yeah.
Sometimes though,
but sometimes faggots the right word for the job.
That's what's unfortunate is I ultimately decided that it was ineffective
because it wasn't conveying what you're trying to convey.
That's what I ultimately found.
So many people got upset at me for using it.
I'm like,
you're not conveying a,
you're not perceiving what I'm trying to convey.
So it's an ineffective word.
Unfortunately.
I think it's a great word,
but it's ineffective,
you know?
I certainly don't mean homophobic in any way.
Stretch or form.
I think you're born gay and if you don't think someone's born gay,
it's because you know when you're born retarded or,
or your Michele Bachmann's husband.
Oh Wow.
That motherfucker that is going to end with bodies of dead babies.
He killed whole shit.
Dave Foley sent me hip to this guy.
Thank you,
Mr. Foley.
Oh Wow.
Dave Foley,
who's tweeting about how gay,
um,
Marcus Bachmann is and you think that can't be that.
I'm like,
how could he be?
come on,
Dave.
You.
Yeah.
What did he hit on your girlfriend or something like that and what's going on
here,
Dave?
You know,
I go to the link to Dave put up and I went,
oh my God,
these guys need to stop.
Dude.
He is so gay.
He's calling them barbarians.
I mean,
it sounds like Paul Lynn,
I know he sounds like one of the squares and the Hollywood squares.
It states left even barbarians,
sweaty,
muscular barbarian with soar fat Cox.
It's just what is that is going on there?
I know.
Crazy as that Sam's caps,
man,
it's such a sick of movement where they say,
I hope like all of those kids that go to those like anti camps just come back
with so many phone numbers.
Like I hope that's just like,
I hope those four,
that forests or certain things like a gay fuck faster,
there's just so much fucking,
like the trees are ashamed of their,
like,
I shouldn't look at this.
Totally slice is supposed to be magical.
Park went the other way.
I don't know if you saw that.
It was just all these kids just fucking shooting themselves.
Oh.
They're like,
all right,
see you later.
And you just hear like wonder if they wouldn't let,
so I guess South Park kind of gets a free reign.
They can do whatever they want.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean,
this was fucking kids fucking each other to what?
Ellie,
can you have a cartoon kids fuck each other.
And then I allow that.
I saw Carmen does deck.
Yeah.
I think when you,
when you're making that much money,
people were like,
I don't give a shit with comedy central.
Just,
I mean,
they're never really regulated by the FCC.
I don't know how their cable cable is not regulated by the FCC.
Cabled technically can do whatever the fuck they want just because they have
commercials,
which means they're just regular cable.
They're not subscription cable like HBO.
Right.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
My,
that's one of the things I was going to say about my special,
they allowed after 11 on Spike TV and on comedy central after 11:00 PM the aired
at night.
All the words are in fuck,
except faggot.
And you're saying they wouldn't let that one at?
Yeah.
Where do you live?
I Brooklyn.
Brooklyn.
Hard Keegan in Brooklyn now man.
We have like Vegan pizza delivery places and Chinese food and like we take
whenever my wife's parents come in and they get like chicken parm sandwiches and
like cheesecake and shit and like they don't taste the fucking difference.
So you said something that was very important at the beginning we were talking
about honey and that you are a pro,
you use honey has some vegans that don't want even bees work and for that how it
is ridiculous.
You're not like super hardcore.
Do you do soy?
These are cons.
Uh,
yeah,
I yeah,
I will do.
So I don't do it that much just cause it's like processed and like I'm like I'm
going to go vegan.
I want to be like healthier.
You know?
Especially since I started like fighting,
I'm like a lot more,
you didn't want to cry while doing Jujitsu and I didn't want to say estrogen and
stuff like that.
[inaudible] had a mama is in a meeting,
he starts making milk.
We had Dick Gregory on our show on Monday.
Right.
And he's like this fascinating dude who you want to talk to you because of all
of his stances,
you know,
uh,
I can see,
you know,
and he's the one who pulled out the Zapruder film.
Did Gregory brought the Zapruder film to the Geraldo Rivera Show?
I did many years.
Holy Shit.
I didn't know the history.
That was fascinating.
I mean,
this guy's made his,
I mean he marched with Martin Luther King Jr he was the first black comic to
play an all white nightclub because you have no higher him.
Right.
Uh,
but he's also 80 years old and like Jordan.
So we're just asking like a simple question where it's just like,
oh,
how do you feel about the death penalty was like my grandkids.
Soy makes you gay.
And like,
it just like kind of trailed all over the place.
But yeah,
he brought that up,
uh,
on Monday.
I think he might be a Kim trail guy too.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I was really big into soy soil.
Then I switched up on in,
but when I was in the soil,
I could totally feel like I was just really emotional.
I never really felt it.
I just assumed,
I just assumed it was because I was a comic.
I'm like,
God,
I have hated myself pre soy,
but all my milks,
the shit.
Yeah.
The soil.
There's been like research lately about saying like all this evidence,
like it's bad for asthma,
lies soil.
Yeah.
And like how there's like babies,
it's supposedly like there's reports lately and I you shouldn't give baby soy
that there's some bad shit going on somewhere in the middle.
I mean,
any process for,
it's pretty bad.
That's why I love,
it's like you switched from regular milk to soy milk to almond milk and you look
at the ingredients and I was like all mince.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's what you want.
You know what I mean?
Like whenever,
uh,
whenever you do a sub,
it's like,
that's what's cool about the Vegan subs.
It's like,
so,
so milk's not really great for you.
Right.
Um,
especially if you're not getting,
you know,
it's pasta and antibiotics.
And fucking,
you know,
it's used to fatten up calves like we're not supposed to.
We're the only animal that drinks out of a tit,
a past infancy,
let alone not even our tip.
Another tip.
But you know what?
With cookies,
it's the shit son.
But you stop getting silly.
You can start saying,
you know what else you can use raw milk.
That's what I get.
I get it from whole foods.
It's only good.
It seems like it was worse.
Dangerous,
but
it's like fucking bare back.
All right.
Sometimes you get to take a chance on,
you know you want to live with a condom you whole life.
So I drink raw milk when I have my vegan cookies cause I will eat the fuck out
of some vegan cookies.
I don't know what makes them Vegan,
but they're good.
They're gonna just help me out with chocolate chips.
I did the opposite of a Vegan Diet this weekend.
I was at a hotel that the only thing close to it wasn't Mcdonald's and a seven
11 so I had only at those two places where this was in Montana,
which is so crazy.
This should be eaten.
Bear burgers up there.
I know you're in Montana.
You can get shitty process food.
That was probably,
you know,
have you been there before,
Montana?
Yeah,
I think I was there when I was young,
but I haven't been there in my adult life.
Do you ever murder somebody or kidnap somebody?
Go to Montana.
It's a great place to just hide and live your life.
Or Dane had a great episode on Montana Authors,
authors that live up in Montana.
It was hanging out with them and they were eating wild game and shit and like
shooting pheasants and stuff.
My Buddy Steve,
Steve Graham,
he lived in Montana.
He lived up there for a long time.
He was,
um,
a doctor up there.
It's on his face.
It's like Alison Anhydro after.
I'm actually thought of one of your bits because one of those places where like,
especially if you're used to la or New York or city,
as you drive through a place like Montana or your drive through,
like kind of up above like San Francisco,
but I live in mill valley or somewhere were you can just see these fucking
mountains and it reminds you that like,
oh,
I'm on earth.
Like I'm on a plane.
I'm not like on another fucking highway.
I'm not another fucking best by,
but you strip my,
like I'm on a planet because you just see what it almost looked like before we
fucking strip mall it all up.
You know?
And when I was living in Boulder,
I will,
I was up in the mountains.
One of the reasons why I chose to go up in the mountains,
because the stars,
because what you could see at night to me,
I was like,
look,
people pay a lot of money for artwork.
You know,
on the wall there's no greater artwork then nature,
then looking at mountains and then at nighttime stars.
Yeah,
I mean you see 10 times more stars [inaudible] here because of all the light
pollution that we experienced.
The Sky was amazing,
the stars.
But what was even cooler was how far you could see distance wise.
Like you don't like in La,
you don't realize that.
You can't really see that far.
Most of the time range smoggy.
This you could see miles,
like we saw a storm coming,
like just a black class.
Like it was so cool and it was just a little storm and that went away and was
like,
wow,
that's,
and you can hear shit.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
just here when I was quiet,
when I was up in Colorado,
it was sitting on the porch for fucking hours and just hear like eagles here,
squawk Golden Eagles up there.
You would hear all sorts of weird animals going through the woods at night.
He got a little creepy,
especially after the dog had eaten by a mountain line.
It'll go a little creepy but drink.
But,
um,
but during the day it was,
but you would every day I would see like a porcupine,
like a fucking pig,
porcupine in the middle of the road and have to wait for this fucking thing and
see deer constantly.
A buddy of mine just was biking and he just,
he's in boulder and he ran into a Mousse or riding his bike.
Holy Shit,
that's a moose.
I can go to places like that and you start to think about like our ancestors and
stuff and like the things we complain about,
it's like people hiked across this with like dying relatives strapped to their
back and like searching for wildlife.
That's insane.
I think it's so important to go to a place like that and sit the fuck down and
just,
just reset your brain.
Reset the way you look at civilization.
For me live in the mountains was so perfect because it was only 20 minutes of
boulder.
So in 20 minutes I could get down to the city.
But then I was in,
I was in the woods,
man.
You get to a view of the earth as you were saying.
It's like,
it really lets you put everything in perspective.
Just because there's a giant mass of people down there,
ball buzzing around in a hive doesn't mean you have to be in that totally right.
Everyone you've got to boulder,
that's a pretty big show.
Hippie think made out of co ops and shit.
Yeah,
Boulder's awesome.
Except for this too many headpiece.
Boulder killed my view of hippies.
I had a very um,
sort of,
uh,
idealistic view of hippies,
fortunate boulder in boulder.
They broke me.
It broke me with all their,
their constant requests for things.
It's brutal and they take it like wine hippie step two,
you're far.
So like they were trespassing on my property and I'm like,
hey man,
we can't walk in your drug.
This is all land.
That's the thing when like even with like simple things,
like there was something like amazing Vegan places.
Like I said,
well let's take our family or our friends too when we're in New York.
But then like it be traveling and like sometimes again,
it's just one step too fucking hippie man.
You got there and it's like we don't believe it's silverware man.
I was like God damn it.
Come on man.
Like he really had to fucking do that.
Or you know sometimes I think of liberals had the the um,
and especially hippies if they had the drive of Republicans would fucking win.
Cause sometimes I'll go to something where it's like such a good cause like the
Brooklyn Book Fair or like saying like no one knows we're fucking shit is like,
you know,
or you go to like a protest.
Like people have the wrong sign.
It's like if I can get free to bed or,
and it's like,
no,
you're not even fucking,
that's the wrong one.
You know what I mean?
It's not even that.
And then you look at,
Republicans are on the same page every fucking day.
There's no infighting,
there's no bullshit.
The environmentalist are mad at the vegans are,
the gays are mad at the blacks or whatever.
You just get like 100%.
They wake up at like 6:00 AM and they were like,
Hey,
are you crazy?
It's like you are you crazy?
You have like,
it's all right,
it's a fucking go be crazy.
And then they go and they get shit done because what they like,
what they lack and sort of empathy and facts,
uh,
they make up for in like pamphlet making skills and they're really good at that.
She had organization,
an organization that really get a lobbying and we're just like trespassing on
your work and his properties like,
hey,
freedom.
Do you remember the people that were hired or volunteered when the,
uh,
the voting scandal that was going down in Florida and all the people that were
cheering and throwing their fists up in the nab,
like your around shirts and shit.
It was so creepy.
That was the creepy,
that's one thing that I totally agree with you on that,
that particular situation.
I would never see Democrats doing that exact same old,
I mean,
we'll look at with Democrats,
look at Barack Obama.
I mean,
look at what a gigantic,
gigantic,
a scared little vagina he's been where he's talking about,
uh,
talking about compromise.
It's always talking about that the country wants to stay in office.
The country want to compromise.
The country one compromise.
But here's the ironic part.
So what ends up happening,
he compromises and sells out the liberals,
right?
He compromises before.
There's even like a debate,
like if you're arguing,
if there are 35 hostages,
right?
And Obama's like negotiating,
you're going to end with like 38 dead hostages and abortion is going to be
illegal.
Like that's literally like disguise the way he fuckin operates because he,
he,
he will give them what they want before the debate even starts,
right?
So you're already setting the line to the right instead of how you're supposed
to debate,
ask for a lot,
then start compromising down.
Right?
And the reason,
uh,
Eh,
oh,
so he's doing that because he's saying,
you know,
we're,
we're in a tough economic time.
The Republicans are going to blah,
blah,
blah.
The bottom line is the Republicans on record,
on meet the press on every show have said their only goal is to get Obama out of
office.
So if they're going to do everything they can to fuck you anyway,
why not get what you want unless it's really not what you want.
And that's when I started to think there's more kind of in a clear way,
I don't think it works that way.
I don't think there's really two United groups or think there's all sorts of
factions inside each particular group.
The Tea Party faction of the faction that actually believed that Sarah Pailin
could be fucking president and they have to mingle in with the rest of these
factions.
You know,
the pro war factions,
the industrials factions,
they all get together and then own little group and try to keep things as civil
as possible and keep things moving in the same direction.
But I don't,
I don't really think they're all organized.
I don't think that,
you know,
I don't think they've completely saw the,
the,
the whole picture together and agreed on it.
No,
no.
I mean I definitely don't think it's like the smoky room thing,
but I do think it's that there would be awesome though.
It would be the bill Hicks joke about the Kennedy assassination definitely
explain a lot.
Cause if you don't know how this great joke about when he,
when would someone become president?
They bring you into a dark smokey room,
filled with cigar smoking industrialists of Industry,
roll the clip,
and then it shows you a,
an angle of the President Kennedy assassination that you've never seen before.
And then afterwards it goes,
any questions?
Just what my agenda is going to be.
Yeah.
I mean there's definitely somebody that theory,
but Obama,
I mean,
come on.
Is that,
is there,
is there ever been a bigger turnaround between what you promise in going into
office in which actually deliver?
Has there ever been a,
I don't know,
ever seen a guy that seemed to be a liberal that became a bush.
This is pretty bad.
I mean we'll,
Clinton was a lot more republican than people.
I mean,
you remember the most homophobic legislation was passed in our cloud and all
that telecomm merging that was under Clinton.
What is the homophobic stuff that was passed on to the defense of Marriage Act,
which now Obama shiner the officer.
Where does that come from is well,
who's putting the pressure?
That's what I don't understand.
Why would,
why,
what is the pressure to make gay marriage illegal?
Where's that coming from?
Zero financial benefit in that the insurance company thing,
the religious right.
I mean is it just that though?
Cause it seems like there's gotta be some money in that.
It seems like if in order for it to have so many legs it's,
there's gotta be some money,
you know,
actually care so much.
I kind of wish there was cause ward,
a lot of that stuff can come down to money.
This is legitimately like fucking racism wise.
I mean it's just like it was the next step.
We're all scared.
We need someone to fucking hate.
We need someone to scapegoat because look what's easier saying,
ah,
we have to the,
the entire voting systems rigged or democracy might be broken if you try to fix
it,
are going to be chased down by a bunch of fucking brown shirts.
So we to completely
redo our voting system or blame it on the Mexicans,
blame it on the gaze,
blame it on the poor black women.
It's really easy to scapegoat these people and paint them as like the big
problem or eat mushrooms and wait for the aliens.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Sort everything out.
I don't want to be a part of this civilization anymore.
It's pretty bad.
I'm 43 years old.
42 that's what I'm saying.
I'm not getting into the point where I'm going.
You know what?
You guys are just too crazy and it's been crazy since the 60s it's been crazy
since the 50s I listened to a hunters Thompson speech that he gave at Boulder,
a university in the 1970s and I listened to it the other day on the plane and
when I was listening to that I was like,
wow,
these are the same fucking concerns.
They were worried about the CFR.
They were worried about,
you know,
the,
the end of the world.
People were worried back then about a war with the Soviet Union and like me and
you know,
all this country's going down hill.
This country's going down hill,
me and that was the echoed statement over and over again in the 1970s then here
we are,
2011 things just keep fucking putting along,
man.
I don't,
I don't want to keep trying to fix this fucking thing and wait my whole life
out.
That's my number one problem with politics.
Now I don't want to waste my whole life on some system that I had no say over.
All of a sudden I'm born into this system that in my opinion makes very little
fucking sense.
Seems like it's overrun with douchebags and corruption and there's no ethical
way through.
So I look at him and go,
what?
What,
How much time am I going to waste?
Can I just make some noise in the background and hope they don't get so out of
control that I have to deal with them in my life?
I mean,
is that my option now wait in man,
I'm not getting,
I'm not going in there and you don't want it.
But the problem is it's like,
and you can look at it from kind of like a bad ass point of view.
It's like you look at like these activists,
there was this kid,
oh,
there's this guy named Tim to Christopher.
And of course you got like no mainstream media attention,
even though he was like a likable,
articulate,
funny,
like good looking dude where they were going to auction off all of this land.
He was,
he was really drew me to have a good smile,
like a vampire.
Oh,
I'm drinking soy milk.
I'm sorry everybody.
I apologize.
Um,
and he,
yeah.
Uh,
he,
uh,
they were gonna auction off of the Bush administration was an auction off all
this,
like a protected wildlife and Utah.
Right.
And so,
you know,
Robert Redford trying to stop it and all this stuff,
no one can stop it and they're doing it to drill and this is just like this
amazing land that hasn't been touched.
Um,
and so Tinder,
Christopher's fucking driving to school and he's like,
I have to do something.
This is insane.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
Maybe I'll just purchase,
assign is stupid,
but I have to try it.
So he goes there and notices there's little security and they're letting people
in for the auction and he's just like,
I'm going to go and I'm gonna go in an auction.
Right?
So he goes in,
no one's really noticing him.
It's like he's probably like the only guy,
not in a cowboy hat.
But,
uh,
at least that's how I envisioned it.
And he,
uh,
he helped bids all these oil companies.
He's just keeps bidding and bidding 100,000,
blah,
like buys all the land.
Right?
So they realize he's a fake.
He gets arrested.
What he knew was by the time they restructured everything cause they can't just
do the auction again.
Uh,
Obama was going to be an office and Obama,
uh,
would protect the land.
So it's a really cool,
sort of heroic,
Badass story about activism and about actually changing something.
But the twist is a,
he just got sentenced.
He's going to fucking jail.
So the people who tortured the people who wire tap,
the people who you know,
uh,
kill civilians,
the government that will cut $900 million from the school system in Pennsylvania
will not tax cut giving tax cuts to billionaires.
Those guys are fine.
But this dude who just like,
it was a fucking t.
I mean that was that,
that was old school civil disobedience.
I mean,
the thing is it wasn't a fucking online petition.
It wasn't like you retweeted something.
Fuck Shit Up Moses Physical Act.
Well he,
I guess it was,
it was fraud.
He was posing as,
or I don't know the actual charge,
but he was posing to someone else.
He disrupted this,
uh,
this auction.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know the name of the game.
He went in there and fucking raised his little stupid auction and paddle and
just kept raising it and just lied and fucked up the whole thing.
So He'd lost people money and he's going to jail for the,
yeah,
I think it was a,
I think the sentence might have been like 10 years.
Speaking of Montana,
giant fucking oil spill in Montana.
Have you seen the photos of that?
It's horrible.
Right into the fucking Yellowstone river man.
At least 25 miles between 31 and 42,000 gallons float.
It's a lot of flooding then.
So that's what they were talking about is how everything's flooding right now.
This is not flooding.
Let her know this is oil and the oil spill.
It's horrible man.
This beautiful river and it is just fucking disgusting with oil.
It's so sad man.
If you ever go up to like you know that you were up in Montana,
you know you go to that part of the world like looking at like some of the,
the the rivers and lakes and streams,
the flow through like Colorado and Wyoming and all those like a sparsely
populated places.
There's a few places like that where you can still see some incredible,
you know,
natural,
beautiful things like that and now it's fucked.
Now you probably have a lot of,
you probably have at least some listeners who were like,
you know,
who cares,
we've got to get the oil,
blah blah blah blah,
blah,
like,
or something.
It looks pretty.
Go look on a,
at a,
at a pretty picture,
but people's waters or be employed water is being poisoned.
If you've seen that shit in New York where people come to light their water on
fire.
Yes.
Because of the hydro fracking like insane.
Like people were literally being like poisoned by this shit just for more for
four fucking money.
Yeah.
Well the idea that the only way to go is with oil and the only way to go as a
way that pollutes the environment.
That's ridiculous.
There's,
they found clean sources of fuel.
What they need to do is figure out a way to make clean sources of fuel work for
a large scale of human beings.
That's what they need to do.
Bill Burr had to jack about it.
I never saw him do it.
I'm like,
TV Buy America was working it out of the Boston comedy club when I was starting
in about like somewhere there's like some guy on a farm who like invented like
the perfect like you know,
kind of a electric car or like natural gas and you know,
people come to his door and they're like,
yeah,
we're here from a like whatever committee and they're like,
let's just see the thing.
And then he turned around like it's right here and just funk and just take some
out.
Just
drags him away and like that's it.
You know?
I know there was a guy that invented a car that room water.
It turned up dead a couple of years later.
They were talking about that on the opiod Anthony show.
That's probably where you were talking about were bill Burke came problems on
that episode.
You don't want to be,
you don't want to be conspiratorial sometimes,
but here they were from artilect when you were talking about the fucking whistle
blowers dead dead and you hear stuff like that and it's just like,
all right,
Jesus,
look,
you don't know.
The strange case of Vince Foster,
you know the Vince Foster story,
right?
Oh,
he had a clean beds.
Foster Vince Foster,
some guy who knew a lot of shit about all those creepy real estate deals that
went on where a lot of people went to jail and this guy wound up in a fucking,
uh,
he was one of dead where there was no blood,
there was no blood near the scene of the crime.
The clearly moved his body and the gun was still in his hand,
which is not supposed to ever happen in a suicide case.
When you shoot yourself,
your gun supposedly just goes flying out of your hand.
You can't hold onto it.
Right?
So when someone's got a gun in their hand and there's no blood there,
like I'm pretty sure that's a,
don't quote me on this.
I've read the book,
the strange case of Vince Foster,
the strange death of visit the foster,
I read it years ago for sure.
There's conspiracies,
man.
If you don't think there are,
if you don't think people are getting whacked left and right,
let me tell you how it works.
If you have a lot of money,
you know other people with a lot of money.
If you know other people with a lot of money,
you know other people that have ties to the military.
If you know people that have ties to the military,
you know people are mercenaries.
If you know people live mercenaries and you have a problem when you get that
problem taken care of,
he didn't get it taken care of,
clean for not that much money.
I have friends that it worked as mercenaries.
I have friends that worked for various companies overseas.
They were in the,
they were in the marines and they were in,
you know,
and they wanted to go back and make some money and they went back and they made
a fuck load of money.
And it's not hard to find people like that.
It's not hard at all.
You know,
so anybody that thinks that you can,
you know,
run around fucking over Rupert Murdoch and that end up,
listen bitch,
it doesn't even matter bad.
It doesn't even matter how public it is.
That's how I'm going to say that's the scariest fucking part.
Because like,
let's say that did happen,
right?
That means not only is he just like kill him,
so all right,
already fucking creepy,
right?
Like take him out.
Uh,
but on top of that,
knowing is going to be public.
Nobody's going to be that obvious.
Like,
couldn't even wait a fucking year.
It's almost dead,
man.
He's almost dead.
He's got a special cell phone that he keeps in his backyard.
He has to pick up a rock.
He turns it on and he calls some dude.
It looks like Charles Bronson,
but talks in a Russian accent and that's your ass bitch.
Fucking,
he's an Australian.
Mr. Burns from the Simpsons.
It ain't hard,
dude.
It ain't hard.
Trust me.
There's a lot of Goddamn people.
People can blend in and there's like 7 billion people on the planet.
You don't think they could find someone to kill you?
Run Louise Boat,
by the way.
I hope you don't mind.
I'm sleeping over and now and just find that leaving the house.
Oh,
you scared a little bit.
Don't be scared,
dude.
You're not saying anything bad.
I don't think they would kill you for that.
I don't think so.
If you've got to,
you've got to be some wiki leaks.
Tech Shit.
Yeah,
there's a part of me that gets disappointed every time that like security,
they pass me along.
I'm like,
I'm not as edgy as I thought.
Do you really think that like maybe you will wind up on the list someday for
being an edgy comedian?
Yeah.
For one day.
One day.
I fucking hope so.
I hope so.
Cause I,
I just get bored of my fucking act that I'm like,
you sound that dude.
Uh,
the hacker thing.
So,
uh,
you brought up Bradley Manning.
I was just watching this interview with the one guy who was pretty much has
access to them.
This Guy David House,
we didn't actually bring him up.
He's the guy who wrote the Wiki leaks guy.
He's the,
uh,
the soldier that gave up all the information and Juliana Song as part of this
whole like hacking community.
I'm like,
I want to get someone on our show where like,
you got to look into that.
Like this community is fucking fascinating.
So I'm watching this kid to be interviewed and he's this really like a really
fucking smart guy.
And I guess he was at a hacker conference and they can like spot out cause
there's always like FBI agents and stuff like that.
And apparently there were showing vintage footage of the civilians that were
killed.
The first big thing that came out from wikileaks from,
from the helicopters.
So they were showing footage of this and a horrifying horrifying.
And this Guy David House was very calmly explaining.
So I was sitting in the audience and I saw the guy next to me was an agent and
Amy Goodman there,
the woman interviewing him was like,
how'd you know?
He was an agent?
And this was like some Jason Bourne stuff.
He's like,
was blackberry was tinted so he can see it at an angle.
He was wearing khaki pants and a hacker tee shirt,
which is the memo they all get when they all get emails to say to dress like us,
except he had a shaped head that symbolized military or law enforcement.
So I leaned over to him and said,
just so you know,
you're supporting this.
And the guy goes,
yeah,
yeah.
And then he left.
But it's like how fucking creepy is that when you're involved in this just a
hacker convention and it's just like,
you know that like you're saying,
but it's like the guys,
like when I,
when I was 60,
I used to go to a phish concert.
You see the guy with like the old tie dye shirt that's like,
is anybody selling illegal narcotics?
And they're like,
are you sure you're a cop dude?
Yeah.
I had a guy come up to me and Cleveland asked me for DMT.
I'm pretty positive he was a cop.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was like asking me like,
really?
Come on,
I ain't,
I get it.
Yeah.
And it was looking at the zone and so I was like,
what are you talking about man?
Yeah.
It was weird.
He had a crew cut and he was asking me about how to get DMT and like,
I don't know how to get illegal drugs,
dude.
Wow.
We've had people at,
uh,
we've got people at like our meetups and stuff,
be like,
you know,
so when do you think,
when do you think violence is?
Okay?
And we're just like,
we're done.
We're done here.
You know what I mean?
Like,
let's look at you say it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's kind of funny man.
That they could spot the hackers that easy or a spot.
The FDA agents that are,
excuse me,
the hackers could spot them.
I thought that was silly.
I know,
I know.
It's so ridiculous.
But you know,
when you have people,
I mean,
there are people infiltrating like peace groups course and it's a,
and it's crazy.
It's like that's where you're gonna put your,
you know,
you say you're going after fucking al Qaeda and trying to keep us safe,
but really the antiwar people,
you're afraid to it that are going to commit violence.
I forget the pot story.
Something about some growers up in the northeast or northwest or other,
and the way they found out that there was a,
um,
uh,
an inside guy that was a,
a grower that was actually an FBI agent was he died in a motorcycle accident.
I remember that it was revealed as a state cop.
They covered under [inaudible] what the fuck.
Like you,
you,
you would've,
would've,
would've waste of money you guys are doing here.
It's so ridiculous.
We interviewed like this,
like hardcore
animal activist is getting Peter Young who was like part back in the day.
It was part of the Animal Liberation Front.
Like,
oh,
those guys are,
no one went to jail for arson and shit.
Well though,
they don't think you should even have pets.
They think that every animal should be free.
Oh,
interesting.
That's their ultimate goals to release dogs and trip.
Most of the animal activists that,
like I talked to our,
uh,
incredibly pro adoption,
they're anti breeding,
but like,
yeah,
of course,
pro adoption.
Um,
but anyways,
so,
uh,
so he actually had a woman,
he essentially was dating an FBI agent.
Like she infiltrated that way when all these road trips and just started asking
all the right questions and he was banging her while he was at least we kind of
alluded he was at least like hooking up and what does that mean,
the cop to suck his dick?
I'm like that.
It's more worth it.
Do a little jail time.
You know you fucked the shit out of that cup.
But I like what level of like evil is like that boss that it's like,
go fuck this guy for information.
What level of evils that girl and she can do that.
Yeah,
seriously.
Wow,
that's dark dude.
Yep.
Ooh,
that's someone's daughter.
Someone's daughter used her pussy to catch some animal terrorist guy.
You know you're a snitch and kind of a slutty like you're both of those things
dirty bitch or they just said that they arrested 14 people from it anonymous
today.
Oh,
they'd been arrested as part of an ongoing operation targeting the hacking
collective.
Goddammit Joe,
we are on the list.
I'm staying here.
Does it just happen?
Listen,
I'm going to Republican fundraiser tomorrow or you want to go?
I
might want to join in,
dude.
I man just cut your hair a little closer to the scroll and wear a long sleeve
shirts.
The light man.
Yeah.
No people see the light.
They'll be excited.
They'll feel it.
They'll feel edgy.
Do they want to have one that was,
cause we have tattoos,
dude.
We fucking talk to a different group of people that they don't know.
It's access to some people,
you know,
they don't get those democracy now characters,
you keep fucking put some sense into their head through you serious dude,
I,
I have to tell you,
I series man,
this Miller the whole deal.
He did,
right.
Oh,
what happened man?
I'm wanting to ask him once,
man,
I've only talked to him a few times.
I've talked to him on the rear,
on the radio,
on his show.
And this has been very cool to me and I liked him.
He's a very nice guy.
Sure.
And,
but one time we were alone in the bathroom taking a leak right next to each
other and they're just trying to be like this is an act.
Right.
Cause he was,
this was 2003 this when fear factor or just starting to take off it goes Joey
got yourself full hit there.
Congratulations.
Or peeing next to me feel that I want to go.
What the fuck is going on?
I know Bush you hanging out with him.
What happened?
What does that like you're going and hanging out at their house and an FBI
agent.
This is fucked up.
You have an HIA.
What's weird?
Cause I think he was legitimately,
I think a lot of people got very like after nine 11 they definitely like
legitimately at least on the war on terror front got a little republican each
cause everyone was fucking scared.
Right?
Rightly so.
But then I just saw him recently on like Bill O'reilly and 70 he's like making
fun of poor people and Shit like that.
It's like,
dude,
you can be Republican on one level and not have to sell out everything
you used to believe in.
Like that's your kind of blows my mind.
Like someone said to me like,
Whoa,
wait,
you get some money and you'll,
you'll become a republican.
And like that was some of the most insulting she had where it's like,
so you're saying that what I be kept money,
I'm just going to sell out everything I ever believed in.
Like I'm sure there are people who do it,
but Jesus Christ,
man,
how can you be so shallow to say that and be okay that that came out of your
mouth?
Yeah.
It's so silly to think that you would all of a sudden join that other team and
you know,
you have a pretty open minded spectrum of ideas that you've adopted from a bunch
of different places.
Yeah.
Well you would all the sudden go,
no,
I'm here to protect all my goal.
You know,
instead of,
instead of being open minded and kind of like looking at the whole big picture
and said,
well they're both kind of crooks and you know what you do,
you know,
you wouldn't do that.
You'd all sudden become a Republican.
It's so ridiculous,
you know,
and get some money.
Yeah,
I start prayer.
The best thing money gives you the best thing is you don't worry about money.
That's the best thing money gives you.
Yeah,
I'm sure it's the number one thing it gives you people who don't,
you know,
they'll look at it like,
like Oh man,
it's not all about money.
You're right.
But it's like a tool.
It's not all about hammers,
but if you want to build a fucking house,
maybe you shouldn't have a hammer.
Right.
Okay.
Cause Hammers are awesome to build houses with.
You going to use rocks and nail those nails.
You could build a house with a rock and,
and,
and nails.
But you're way better off making some money.
Right.
We,
we've been her off figuring out how you don't have to get rich.
Just get to a point where you can be comfortable.
You don't have to wake up in a fucking sweating.
Like I always used to do exactly what you were like,
fuck,
how am I going to feed myself this week?
Yeah.
Well,
when you get to a point where you don't have to worry about those things,
you're not going to change and become a Republican.
You're not going to fucking all of the sudden say fuck the world I needed,
which Wa that's ridiculous.
Get his any republican who doesn't have $1 trillion.
You know what I mean?
Who isn't just so rich?
And it's like,
I think it's because they,
and again,
our representation,
the Democrats representation liberal stereotype,
like it's horrible.
But anytime I talked to like a level head,
a conservative,
and like we actually have a conversation,
we realize we're all being fucked by the same people.
Right?
And the bottom line is Republicans have gotten really good as,
what did they say?
They say,
we don't want to raise taxes.
So if you're poor,
you're middle class,
you hear that and you go,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Because I need every penny that I can get.
What they're actually saying is we're not going to raise taxes on the upper 1%,
which the majority of people are not.
Obviously the upper 1%.
So that means that someone who already has $1 billion,
it doesn't want to give away a tiny percentage of that,
which they won't even fucking notice is there.
And because of that,
that's going to defund however many schools that's going to,
uh,
you know,
that money could have been used to create jobs,
to create infrastructure with all these fucking bridges that are collapsing.
Right?
And so it's not you.
They don't want to fucking rob you all the,
the Bush tax cuts.
Look,
they're talking about the debt ceiling right now.
We've raised the debt ceiling under every recent president.
The only one we didn't,
the only one who didn't George Bush raise the debt ceiling several times over.
We don't want it.
There's a black president.
The last thing you want him to do is running up his credit card.
That's very true.
That's what's going on.
This guy's trying to get shit on layaway.
Is it?
We know how they are.
They're very bling bling.
But the only one did the worry fancy.
The only one who did it or their fancy,
the only one who didn't raise it,
that's the name was Bill Clinton because we actually had a surplus under
Clinton.
Then Bush came in and I remember a lot of these same republicans who are cutting
all the,
this,
the,
the funding from Medicare and stuff.
Uh,
there,
they're still an office.
They were in an office with Bush.
Bush comes in and cuts tax cuts for the rich,
uh,
and goes to war and suddenly we all this money and we're back in bed and it's
like,
it wasn't,
it wasn't the democratic problem with taxes.
My number one problem is,
you know,
saying that you're going to take away more money from people,
whether it's from rich people or whether it's from poor,
where would the fuck you it?
Yeah.
I don't trust you to manage that money correctly.
So I don't believe that if you take more money from rich people,
it is going to necessarily fix anything.
I think it's probably going to create a bunch of fucking jobs that we don't
really need.
That's what's really gonna happen.
It's gonna get more money for taxes and what does this incompetent fucked up
government going to do?
What they're going to create more jobs to to require more money so they can
continue to get more taxes every year.
I don't believe that it's going to funnel directly into education.
Yeah.
I mean that community improvement as I did,
if I thought it was handled by competent people,
I would support it.
But when you start talking about 48% tax brackets and ridiculous shit like that,
I got to go,
where's this money going?
And Are you getting a a direct result,
a fair proportion of resources for what you put in?
Well that's a problem is so it's passionate up a system that's completely
fucked.
Well,
the on the backs of the successful people,
I think in the success,
sorry,
I will just say one more thing and I do agree that successful people have made
it to be successful because of this system and they should,
could probably contribute more.
I absolutely think that,
but I think I don't trust the people that are in charge of doing it to be
competent in it.
Who the fuck would want to be handling taxes?
Right?
Who the fuck would be wanting to be distributing wealth and,
and doing it,
you know,
uh,
all these people are paying taxes.
You've got to figure out where the fuck it goes.
God Man.
Who the fuck would want that some creep?
Yeah.
Well don't get me wrong.
I mean there's definitely something in the middle of like,
I want to say socialism works,
but if I could have been on the underground farm and see the hell and that can
break colors there,
everyone has been on a message board just kind of like,
all right,
maybe we need some totalitarian socialism doesn't work because there's too many
weak cons.
There's too many lazy fucking people who are not going to do their share.
If everyone was cool and every one was of sound character and we had this sort
of a,
a community where,
you know,
I need a coconut.
You A,
you know,
you can let me borrow some woods.
I remember a lot of these legacy costs are,
you know,
whenever you say lazy con are you say Welfare Queen,
what do you think of you think of the fucking end,
some poor black family who has like,
I don't think of that saying lazy white guys.
So many of the pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
People were born into that wealth and they're like,
why don't you do what I do?
It's like what?
Go come out of your mom's badge.
Like there's nothing.
I can't be born into what your real issue is.
The numbers are out of control.
There's too many human beings that we're trying to manage.
We're supposed to be in small tribes of 5,200 people.
We should know each other shit in my for you,
because I don't
know the answer to this because I don't not agree with you.
What you said about the government being an APP,
you know this is the first year that a citizen radio actually like we pay taxes
on it,
right?
And there was part of me,
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm fucking proud.
Like this is this.
This is one,
I could have turned it to a Republican,
but I'm gonna,
I'm gonna pay tax,
I'm gonna fun schools,
I'm going blah blah blah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
mailed off the check and then I was like,
that's probably going to kill some Iraqis.
You know what I mean?
Like you don't know where that fucking money is going on.
But with that said so,
but what's the other option?
So it's either you have been an ex patriot,
Thailand.
Yeah,
Noble Shit off the Internet in Thailand with taxes,
you either have the inept government you were talking about,
right.
Or the greedy for profit Republicans.
Both are Shitty,
but what's fucking worse?
And then it's a good question.
What's the in the middle?
Do you ever think about that?
Because you were a really extremely politically,
politically active guy and your,
your radio show is based around,
I mean essentially a lot of it is of our own politics of Noam Chomsky's you ever
feel like,
man,
maybe I'm a commentator on pro wrestling or any,
this is awesome.
Fucking phony horse shit.
And I'm caught up in this pretending it's all real.
And getting everybody,
you know this
Glenn Beck,
September 12th rally to the American,
you're a part of the problem almost.
Yeah.
Almost
legitimizing this horse shit now.
I mean,
I think,
I think it's,
I think it's really easy to think that because again,
it seems,
by the way,
it's just a question.
It's just a question.
Yeah.
And the people are out dealing.
Get you mad.
You were attacking him for being active.
Absolutely not.
I'm just proposing this and I don't,
I don't necessarily mean
that way or the other way.
Well,
people could either be like,
you're attacking him for being accurate.
Be like,
talk about tits.
There's a lot of that makes a lot of talk about farts right now.
Eating my girlfriend's asshole this weekend.
You got caught.
[inaudible] grown man caught me eating my girlfriend's ass.
Those happen.
We,
she's featured dancing.
So we're in the green room and were born.
I'm like,
can I just start eating her asshole?
I thought I locked her door and the guy walks in and goes,
oh,
sorry.
And I had to,
I wasn't an invitation for you to completely change the subject.
By the way,
the Oh fucking Weirdo.
I'll try to segue back.
The old asshole eating industrial complex
when you're trying to eat some ass.
Brian has been banging way over his head so just allow him cause indiscretion
standard.
Very happy,
very happy to have a girl,
doesn't want to have anything to do with him and he can eat her asshole at the
drop of a dime.
So he likes to talk about anything.
So just like entertaining though because he doesn't understand that it's really
for other people.
They're like,
yeah,
yeah.
All right dude.
Show.
You know how horrible it was talking like a grown man,
like,
like he didn't leave and be like,
oh I'm sorry.
He was still talking to my girlfriend going like instructions for it to do
something and I had to like slowly stand up,
sit there and just act like I didn't slowly wipe your mouth with,
well at least you didn't get douchey like most boyfriends of strippers would.
Yeah,
no,
it's really funny when they have rules,
chicks yet on the stage,
now you're fucking creep.
Meanwhile,
she's out there s shoving dildos in her mouth and shit.
That's okay.
Those are ours for my home into
the room without knocking.
Right.
You know?
Yes.
They knocked to make sure that she's okay.
Is a certain amount of privacy that you must respect.
Oh,
I didn't know you're getting your ass hole Eaton.
Yup.
It's weird how much feature dancing and comedian goes together.
Like it was exactly like being on the road with you except that you,
you,
you know,
you don't take off your clothes but in stuff like that and play cooter ball.
But it was exactly the same that you get picked up at the airport and you have a
hotel.
Like it was so weird.
You hate your father.
And then the club operated the same.
It's gotta be a weird stalkery thing.
No,
she isn't.
She,
we're in the middle of Montana and there she's dancing and they know that she
has fans.
I guess she even has fans that are like Twitter fans that are awesome,
that knew who I was just because of falling her on Twitter.
So they wanted to meet you too.
Now they just stared at me and like Hamilton Gade dance with your Carol frame.
He is way dances.
Like lap dances.
Yeah,
I would murder everybody just started [inaudible] she like,
she has to like sit on dude's lap.
So Dude's off the Internet.
They know you girlfriend and then they go and they can get lap dances from your
girlfriend.
Absolutely.
What the good thing is is that she goes and goes,
okay,
I have time for two.
I would've picked this old rich couple over here and dance for his wife and I
might choose that big fat old kid with the glasses that looks like he's never
been laid.
So she'll just do that instead of like she gives away charity.
Pussy.
Yeah.
I think there was like a fraternity there at that odd and wouldn't do any of
them.
I know people who are swingers,
you know,
and I don't this,
I don't know.
That's,
that's the next level.
I do know people,
I know people who will get together as couples and they'll go and try to fuck
other couples and they're like,
be in the room,
watch some guys railing your wife.
Just fucking the shit out of her and they get off on it.
Yeah.
Like what,
uh,
me and presents it to this podcast at this convention we were at and uh,
it was really interesting.
He was kind of was hoping you weren't going to say me and preventative.
We're going to gang bang,
uh,
each other lap dances hoping I'm fucking,
his wife I episode of the Green Room hasn't aired yet as an admin on the show
somehow.
Yeah.
Premiered last week.
Um,
and uh,
I said she really good man for the first,
uh,
the first I was said it was like channeling and Apatow and fucking,
anyway,
so,
uh,
so fucking,
so we were in this podcast and he was kind of going after me for being like a
prude and stuff cause he's like,
yeah,
he's very like in that sort of sexual revolution.
And uh,
and so there were a bunch of grood how will you approved?
Oh,
I mean,
just like very like a meat and potatoes.
Fucking not swingers and that,
you know what I mean?
Like those fucking some happy days type shit.
Yeah.
Everyone's in a good mood and like,
we're like,
we're doing this all right,
let's fuck.
And uh,
and so masks or ball gags or,
yeah,
it's pretty like,
it's pretty,
there's not much you have to clean
up afterwards.
Like we can still look at each other in the eye,
you know,
breakfast together without happy and like what you did was awful.
Um,
and,
and Paul asked,
you know,
he's like,
how many girls in here?
I have rape fantasies now.
We were not,
we were not in like,
uh,
with like dancers or anything.
I was fucking science convention and there were girls in the room,
a big,
small,
pretty unattractive,
uh,
probably 18 to like 40 and married.
All of them raised their hands,
by the way,
it doesn't give the audience too.
If the audience is listening,
I'm like,
oh,
well if that's what they want.
But I was definitely where I'm like,
man,
there was a lot of sexual shit that I do not know about.
Like,
they'll never understand what it's like to be a woman.
We,
we've tried to pretend we do,
but I think you know how like a woman will never understand what it's like to be
you and you just kind of try to be cool round her and try to be what she would
like from you.
It's not the fuck it up when things down just to keep anybody from getting
crazy.
Well it's with that,
with them even though much more extreme way.
We don't know what the fuck it's like to want to get held down and fucked.
Right.
Cause I used to date a girl who was a very nice person and she was very educated
and she like getting held down and fuck.
She would try to get up.
That was her thing.
She was fucking smart man.
She had,
I don't want to say what school she went to,
but she was a very,
very,
very bright person.
Very highly educated and she liked getting raped there.
Okay.
That was her thing.
And She just wanted to get raped by somebody she liked to force.
Yeah.
That was where the thing was.
I couldn't understand that.
I don't know.
I didn't understand it.
But there's nothing like a huge difference between,
you know,
no one wants to get my,
hey everybody,
sorry.
I was young back then and I was quite a bit more savage than I am now.
I'm quite a bit more civilized,
so I was really worried like I would like really get into rape and chicks this.
She might,
she might be my fucking
thing that I didn't know about it.
She was really hot and she was really kind of crazy and fun,
you know?
And so I was like,
shit,
I hope I don't like just get into this.
Right.
This isn't my new thing now.
You know?
I don't want to need to rate people.
Yeah,
that's right.
I like,
like you know,
you look,
obviously we don't completely understand how human behavior comes to fruition.
We know that there's factors,
but we don't completely understand all of them.
Yeah.
I mean it's very possible that something could happen to turn you down a dark
road.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know if it has to happen during the formative period of your,
of your life or if it's possible for some weird shit to happen.
Like if you go to prison or you get addicted to a drug and it also may not even
be like as darker road as like,
you know,
you think it is because I again,
I don't think,
you know,
obviously they wouldn't want to get raped.
Uh,
but it could just be like people like aggressive sex,
you know,
guys fantasize about aggressive sex.
The same thing,
you know,
you don't want to get rid of it.
Just the,
the,
she wanted to fight back when no,
there was a little rape of wow.
I they did girls get slapped and I was like always like free.
Like at first I was just like,
I don't want to do this.
And I was thinking it later in life.
Am I going to start elbowing her?
I didn't realize when I first started dating her why she wanted to date me in
the first place.
Cause I was,
I had never graduated college.
I went to Umass Boston.
I just say that she went to Harvard and,
um,
she just,
uh,
she was just,
Oh,
Becky,
shut the fuck off.
Sorry.
But,
um,
you know,
what she wanted was,
some young savage person,
right.
The fuck the shit out of her.
It's just like a guy who's an intelligent guy.
Like I've seen,
I know a guy who was an executive that lost his entire career because he was a
brilliant guy just of stop.
He couldn't stop going after young hot pussy.
Like he would,
he would and eventually got them in all sorts of trouble,
but it was young,
dumb,
hot pussy.
That's what he wanted.
That's what does grow on it.
Yeah.
It's interesting Matt,
and like,
and,
and you know,
I don't like dudes who used the whole like biological things,
like as an excuse to cheat,
but there definitely is something there.
But like,
anytime that,
like there's a girl,
and especially for comics because like,
I mean,
you,
uh,
you were probably,
I'd read a situation and maybe,
but like,
I didn't get girls until I became a comic.
Um,
so there's part of me that I'm like,
I'm making up for fucking last time
this wasn't fair.
Like,
this is for every fucking girl that was like my best friend and just like fucked
me over and called me when her boyfriend like was a Dick,
you know?
And so I just started fucking and fucking and,
uh,
and say,
look,
you're marching
for holidays.
And uh,
and,
and uh,
and I just remember like,
uh,
I don't even know where that was going.
Like I think was part of me.
There's just like,
yeah,
I did that.
Ah,
that was awesome.
But you were saying,
so then,
uh,
so now,
you know,
like,
I'm like so happily fucking married,
like I don't think about it,
you know,
once you get someone on like an intellectual level,
even like the hottest girl can come up to you and a second she's just dumb or
mean or selfish,
you just becomes like,
just not hot.
So anyway,
so the point though is you've experienced that.
Yes,
exactly.
That's the thing that some people never have.
And some people,
their relationships are always just sexual nature.
Exactly.
Taller than,
yeah,
that's what it becomes easy to cheat nowadays.
Like anytime I've even like,
you know when you have like a hot girl for like a split second and talk to you
after a shower,
when you were like,
oh,
did you get nostalgic for the old days?
Or whenever you go home to your hotel,
you jerk off and it,
it's,
it's the,
it's the best kind of jerking off because it's not,
uh,
not just sexual,
but it's also such a mental relief because you forget when guys fantasize about
cheating,
all they think about is like the fucking or the comic.
They forget about like the conversation that leads to that.
They forget about how would the conversation afterwards,
afterwards,
the awkward section,
you know,
how about the six months where you're like,
oh,
is she crazy and get to pretend to be fucking pregnant.
Like,
how about,
oh,
that shit,
all that shit.
You totally forget about it.
And then once you jerk off,
I'm like,
you know,
the worst thing I have to do fucking clean up,
get,
I have a friend who is,
he?
He's,
he's so crazy.
Like he's always banging the nuttiest chicks over.
This girl blew him and was trying to convince him that she's pregnant.
Stop
it.
Yeah,
she's that crazy.
I go,
how crazy these girls,
he goes,
the craziest,
just the worst.
I'm just nuts.
And I go,
what the fuck is wrong with you,
man?
You're letting these people into your life like you're letting insane people
into your life and the only,
the only standard they have to reach as a sexual one.
All right?
You don't,
you don't need to know that much about their personality.
You don't care.
You're just so crazy.
You let some nutty bitch suck your Dick and now you're trading phone calls with
her and you have to change your phone number because she's trying to convince
you that she blew you and got pregnant.
Check gives me such anxiety,
some naughty ones out there,
man.
Fucking people out there.
Some are there could be just a weird deformed baby.
Maybe it actually happened just like you have to believe it maybe.
Well,
there has been one,
the African story that's a,
uh,
believe it's a true story.
I don't think it's been debunked.
A woman got in a knife fight shortly after she gave a guy a blow job and then
she became pregnant and the reason she became pregnant because the knife went
into her.
You know her whole fucking girly parts under to load actually carry through from
the knife into the a womb.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hope this is a bullshit story.
I hope it's not a bullshit story.
I don't want to review it because I like to tell it.
I hope it's still real hot.
This I have no vagina.
That was the point.
That's the reason why it was so interesting.
The woman was,
she's African.
She was born with no vagina and that's why it was crazy that she got pregnant.
They're going to be a lot of knife fighting.
Vaginalis women listening to this show that are very upset.
Right?
I don't know.
I can't do what many more.
That was the one fucking pleasure I had was knife fighting after a good blow
job.
Well,
I don't believe in the immaculate conception.
I don't believe in the Virgin Mary.
I don't think that's a miracle,
but maybe the messiah comes from a blowjob knife fight.
Maybe that's the Messiah that maybe that child will grow up and realize the
folly of his ways.
Everything.
Yeah.
What kind of a woman's looks at Dick and then gets in a knife fight.
His mom must be fucking crazy.
So from the get go,
he's going to have to figure out things for himself.
So you know,
it might be what's going on.
That might be the Jesus.
I'm pretty,
let's go with that.
It was going to,
so keep an eye on him,
man.
Somebody get them around then that Marcus Barkman guy.
Man,
I can't figure it out.
Figure it out.
If that little African boys,
the Jesus,
I hope I,
I hope,
I hope so.
Cause I'm like if,
if the,
if the religious people are right and if there is a guide right now and if there
is like a Jesus,
like you're,
you guys are cons,
you're letting a lot of bad shit happen.
I think this whole world is a fucking illusion,
I think is just a really complicated,
fantastically created figment of your imagination.
Fig Newton,
you're living your figment.
I'm living my figment.
And they all combined together in some sort of a weird fucking quantum physics
soup.
That's what I think the older I get,
and the more pot I smoked,
slippery or reality gets folks.
I'm not buying it anymore.
Guys named Wiener get busted for taking pictures of their Dick.
And when the war keeps rolling on the Internet is true.
That is funny to think about.
Like it's just someone fucking with us.
Like,
let's see if they,
let's see if they buy this shit.
Really?
You couldn't put it together after the wiener thing.
Keep going.
I think as the apocalypse gets closer and closer,
it's going to be more and more ridiculous.
You know?
I think that's what furries are all about.
I think that that's what this world is all about,
man.
It's as,
as we get closer and closer to the end of our each individual lives,
our imagination is going to spiral this nutty fucking reality further and
further out of control.
It's like the Truman show,
but we just didn't figure it out.
We just kept were like,
this is nice.
Dot Dot,
dot.
It's just way more complex.
You know what I mean?
If you listen to Kurtzweil or any of these futurists that talk about the
potential artificial realities that will be constructed in the near future,
you know,
within uh,
uh,
you know,
a lifetime for sure they will be able to construct some sort of an artificial
reality that is indistinguishable from this room.
Well,
that's why I love,
that's why I love science so much more than religion and kind of do AIG
spiritual shit is because like,
I feel like with religion people were like,
I'm done.
We figured it out.
I'm a science.
Like what's the goal?
The science of science is to keep asking questions is to prove yourself wrong,
is to keep looking and looking and looking.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that to me like you can't just say you're fucking done.
You would have to keep looking like that.
I mean that could be one of the points of life's just,
it's just figuring shit out.
It certainly is,
but I think there's something to religion as well.
And what,
what is to religion is,
even though it's not real,
if you believe it's real,
it can do amazing things for you,
man.
It's a mental thing.
Really.
Yeah.
Well it's,
there's something to the extreme positive thinking.
There's something to the idea that,
you know,
you are working towards God's goals,
and if you really truly believe that,
I think that's incredibly empowering,
sort of.
I think it's empowering in the sense that like there are definitely people who
are like,
I'm working for God and then like get abortion doctor.
And I was like,
wow.
Well there is that.
And that's unfortunate,
but that's not in the,
in the mind of God,
the mind of the true Christian religion,
ideas of God.
It's love your brother,
love people as if they were you.
Have you ever thought about this though?
Cause like,
so that's what I used to say.
Right?
And then,
uh,
two things happen.
Uh,
and they're both completely fucking,
I hate talking about it.
Uh,
but the first one was,
so I was very like spiritual,
but not religious,
right?
Where I'm lacking
well,
religion.
So it sounds like what a stripper was a yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Or just like everybody in college,
why don't you smoke it?
Yeah.
Well it kind of spiritual,
but not really,
really
it be,
there's gotta be something out there.
Yeah.
That was,
that was may.
And uh,
and I remember,
uh,
I use this kind of guy cause you can,
you can do the opposite of what you were doing.
Like I remember I go,
uh,
I would,
we were at Niagara Falls and I pulled this shit on my wife who's a,
who's an atheist and I did the thing that's so many people who are spiritual but
not religious do or it's just like,
look at that,
look at that magical,
how would you say that's something didn't create it.
She very politely walked me over to the sign that told me how Niagara Falls was
made and I was like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Like that's really fucking cool.
And like I would have never thought about that before.
And when it comes to what you were saying with like that doing something greater
than yourself.
I was actually much more selfish until I was atheist.
And if you
actually look at a like a map and pulls to the most,
uh,
charitable countries are the most secular.
So why is that?
Because we always think of religion is doing all these charities and stuff with
the majority of charities are doing number one,
just go right back to the church.
Sure.
You have a lot of people helping poor kids in Africa,
but they're also stealing that condoms and telling them that he just created by
God.
Right.
So that's more fucked up.
I think they're,
the reason the more secular country isn't that a lot of the reason that atheists
are more charitable,
it's cause there were so many times where I see a homeless person or I'll see
something and it wouldn't be affected by it because I'm like God has a plan and
it just kind of gives you this out and it gives you kind of carte blanche just
to ignore shit.
That's a negative aspect of it.
The gating,
the positive aspects of not having like my sister's fucking a born again
Christian and she built a school for poor kids in Saint Louis and I can't be
like,
you're stupid.
The Bible has contradictions.
I'm like,
no,
keep helping the poor kids.
I don't necessarily think it had to be Christian either to just be by by saying
the believing in religion or believing in God,
believing in something.
I think it's,
you can say that it's a mental crutch,
but it can also be a framework for getting through this existence.
Sure.
But I mean they're atheists,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I'm going to [inaudible].
The reality is,
man,
you have a certain amount of fucking time here from beginning to end and the
most amount of this time that you can spend in a positive light,
the the best that's,
that's the best option.
And if you can,
if you can figure out how to enjoy it the most and if the enjoying it is going
by this idea that as you,
as you end,
you will give in to some sort of a higher power that sort of has this,
there's this vision of this the way the world is supposed to be.
But is that almost even,
is that even real positivity in the sense?
Have you ever done psychedelic drugs?
Yeah.
Uh,
just mushrooms.
I think Allison and I are probably not like just like three times.
How big,
how much money?
No,
at once.
Whatever they gave us.
Oh,
okay.
And were you just,
I mean seen God yet homey.
We can straighten that out if you like.
If you guys want to stay an extra day when a girl slumber parties,
you should,
that you need to see man has become legal.
I sure hope you mark it out.
It could be the fucking catch phrase.
Just you haven't seen God homie joy.
It was,
I was saying about that guy who was saying May 21st is going to be the end of
the world and was having all these billboards and God's coming and what were you
going to do when God comes?
You can see God,
you need seven grams of mushrooms and a quiet dark room and you can see God,
you can see everything that anyone has ever thought of ever all at once.
What's so cool about it?
It's like that's fucking with levels in your brain,
right?
And maybe not.
Maybe it's introducing an organic life form from another fucking planet that's
super intelligent and communicates with you through eating it.
Sure.
But both of them are fucking mad.
I mean,
what,
I guess what I'm trying to say is like both of them,
both of them might not be a good thing now.
No,
but mushrooms are an amazing point of them are just as magical because let's say
which side?
It's just as manageable.
Both.
It's either just your brain or if it's some other intelligence,
right?
Because if it's your brain and that's what people,
they're always kind of looking for.
It could be a hyper nutrient,
so I'm sort of a hyper mental nutrient,
so so far science has just,
it fucks for certain parts of your brain,
right?
Well,
they think it actually decreases a certain
amount of blood flow to certain areas.
Yeah,
but they don't totally understand that they need a lot of time doing it and
there's some really cool people doing research,
but I you can't discount,
sorry.
Getting to write about that.
You can't discount the subjective experiences and when people are actually
getting from or how much they're,
they're gaining from it.
Some psychedelic drugs have changed me as a human being.
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
I think they've changed most people who have done it.
What I think so cool is you can say it's a higher power or whatever,
but it's even cooler to me to be like,
or it's me,
it's inside me.
It was my fucking brain is when you've had,
when you've had a real blow outs,
psychedelic experience,
the first thing that happens is you're taken to another place and you don't know
if that other places just some sort of a misfiring of synapses or if it is
actually another place.
But what we do know is that the most potent chemicals are the ones that are
produced by your own mind and the most potent ones in like eating mushrooms.
Mushrooms are,
I think,
I forget the exact chemical term,
but it's like four or five bucks for a lock.
Sully nn dimethyltryptamine I might've said that wrong,
but the point is nn dimethyltryptamine is actually produced by the human mind.
So this is like another form of this human neurochemical.
So there's like a human neurotransmitter and there's a mushroom that fucking
mimics and add some other shit to it.
Yeah.
And when you take this,
you have these incredible experiences and does nothing negative to your body.
No,
for sure.
And you learn from it.
I agree with that 100% well,
I think you need to do some of that shit.
And then rethink this whole God thing because there might be some information
that you're not applying.
And I'm not saying there's God like the Christian Guy,
I'm just saying there's probably an order to,
all of the way I live,
the way I live is this.
I live like they're there.
Like there is no god.
And so what that's done is,
and again,
you know you're not driving,
I live like there is no god.
Why not just live like you don't know because well,
because I always want to because I always want to ask questions.
She would always ask questions and I think that's the key thing.
I think most people who do believe in God said there's definitely a God I would
consider myself when I would you say there's definitely not.
Why wouldn't you can't?
I would say,
right and I would say right now on this podcast,
if a fucking fist came through the ceiling and was like,
I've got,
I wouldn't be like,
no,
you're not man.
I've read Richard Dawkins like I'd be like check.
And I think that's the difference between science and religion is I bet you
could below Richard Dawkins fucking socks off with a powerful DMT trip.
I bet he would come back and he'd be like,
well,
there's some new things to consider.
He'd fucking sit down with his laptop and start writing a whole new book.
That's what Graham Hancock did.
It's all about dragons and cock was all about ancient civilizations and all this
different shit until he went to the jungle and took fucking the Iowasca with the
Peruvian shamans and all of a sudden he wrote that book supernatural.
Or he believes that the entire human race has evolved from monkeys because of
psychedelic chemicals and that these chemicals are getting us in touch with some
sort of higher intelligence that figures the world out for us.
And that's,
that's how human civilization was formed.
I mean,
I think that,
I think the real,
I think that what's proven so far is just as trippy and just as fucking magical
is that that we came from the fucking stars.
You know what I mean?
That we,
that we came from particles of stars that every child,
you can tell every child came from a fucking star and you look at the Big Bang
and you look at the chance that it took and you looked at the way we evolve
using our,
using our brains and amazing physical prowess.
I mean that shit to me blows my mind just just as much.
That's because you've never done enough mushrooms.
I'm telling you man,
there's a big fucking deal to you or does evolution?
No,
it doesn't turn you against anything.
The,
there's clearly,
there's a process of things evolving and becoming.
You mean scientists don't like to use the term evolution for anything that
doesn't include genetics,
but if you just look at social evolution.
Sure.
Look,
can,
we were talking about before,
but we were,
you know,
we both give homage to Lenny Bruce.
Lenny Bruce is one of the pioneers of standup comedy.
If it wasn't for Lenny Bruce,
really there would be no Jamie Kilstein.
There'd be no George Carlin.
It'd be no,
anybody who's out there really saying something on stage that you believe in
that may or may not be controversial or may go against the grain.
He was the originator of that.
Right.
But going back and watching it now is like reading stale academic journals.
Interesting.
I'm not funny.
He's,
he has a few funny lines that will come up with a name and we'll,
you can go around my house,
Dude.
I Have Lenny Bruce Posters.
Oh,
I concert is going of him being arrested.
Yeah.
I've got his shit all over the place.
I pay homage to Lenny Bruce [inaudible] with Bruce and with Hicks.
There's a few of those guys.
You're not supposed to criticize.
You know,
it's supposed to ever say anything.
And you know,
in remotely bad about that.
Even saying that their old stuff is not that interesting anymore.
But I think that's some sort of,
uh,
an,
an evidence of this never ending comp complexity and never ending progress.
And it applies to our culture.
And it obviously applies to the universe from the Big Bang to the cooling stars,
to the single celled organisms,
to multicellular organisms,
to life moving in some sort of a,
it's an,
it's a very obvious direction.
I mean,
my whole deal is,
if you want to believe that,
I think that's amazing.
As long as you,
which you don't stop as long as you don't use that as an excuse to stop asking
questions and keep digging and Campbell,
why would you stop asking questions?
You don't have to stop asking you questions to think that there's some,
some sort of a hyper order to everything,
that there's some sort of loving energy and that positive energy is probably
what this idea of God really is.
But I think that I,
I think that right now it's,
it's not,
it's almost like you're,
you're almost being too optimistic in the sense that a lot of people don't think
that way.
You know?
I mean,
I knew addicts and I'm sure you did,
who,
you know,
went to fucking Aa and they would use a god.
Every time they relapsed they would be like,
oh,
sure.
But higher power,
it is a different plan or I'm,
I'm not really concerned with their errors and thinking what I'm concerned with
is the possible positive affects of thinking that there's some sort of a higher
power.
And I don't mean it in a,
in a sense of one person or one deity or one thing.
I almost mean in terms of just that this dimension,
as complex as it is a supposedly,
you know what is,
you're supposed to be 11 dimensions are something that can be proven.
Quantum physics.
I don't even know what that means.
I'm just talking out of my ass and that none of us can fucking even visualize
that.
But I guess what I was saying is like,
if you have you and Brian Wright and like Brian's being a good person and,
and living his life and,
and loving like everything you said because he loves his family because he loves
eating his girlfriend's ass hole because he lives,
uh,
you know the podcast.
He loves his life,
he loves nature around him.
He loves all that stuff.
And then someone else is doing it.
And again,
this isn't what you're doing,
but for a lot of religious people just talking about finding the positive and
God they do it either because they want to go to heaven and be able to eat a lot
of pancakes and see their dead fucking cat or they do it because they're afraid
to go to hell.
Who's really living the more pure life.
I think it's the person that's doing it for the,
in the moment,
for the right reasons,
for the person.
They love real life as opposed to the people who were doing it because they're
either scared or they're trying to kiss God's ass.
Yes,
I agree.
I think we agreed on that.
Um,
I think we all need to be very careful of,
and I have friends who are atheists that will,
you know,
they will like give me this.
There is no god conversation like Penn Jillette is one of those dudes.
He will give you.
There is no god and you know,
and I've never had a drop of alcohol in my life.
You know,
he doesn't drink.
He doesn't do drugs.
I do anything.
I'm like,
the reason why you saying that,
that's cause you never done any drugs,
right?
If you did some fucking DMT,
you would have some goddamn questions.
You would come back and you'd go,
how was that right there?
How did that happen?
Or how is it that I can take this stuff and I am transmitted instantly to some
place that is beautiful beyond my fucking wildest imagination and filled with
energy and information.
I think all of that shit should be investigated.
And I think the answers could be incredible.
We don't know.
That's the bottom line.
We don't,
we,
we are a fucking a Gnat on an ant's ass trying to figure out the universe.
But if we don't accept that we're crazy having more fucking idiots and were
temporary,
we know that we end,
we end and we want to pretend that we have it figured out.
Leave your fucking mind open,
man.
This could be nuts.
You know,
I don't think it is a man in the clouds with the harp and angels,
but all the Shit that I've seen on mushrooms that's way less crazy.
And I imagine if that's all it was,
if you got there and they're really wants a gate and a dude with a fucking a
thing,
like a book that shows all the Shit you did.
I sit down,
he's like,
are you feel bad about that?
Dot.
I feel terrible.
I evolved.
I grew.
Okay,
come on in.
Yeah.
There really is a fucking guy like that.
That wouldn't be as weird as some of the shit that I've seen you on.
Psychedelics is that reason I always pictured a,
if there was a guy to being the dad from the Little Mermaid,
I don't know why.
Like that's always the fucking name of dance from the Little Mermaid shows that
weird fucking guy with the big beard and the whole crowd.
Although he had a fan,
so I don't know how I'd explain that.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
The the underwater Dad Titan,
I think it is.
I think it's king tide
has involved somewhere
there's,
there's synthetic drugs that do the same as like certain drug,
like you can probably make a synthetic mushroom.
I'm sure that that there is that where you take the same chemicals in it and
they say the same thing
besides silicide.
When there's silicon,
there's,
there's several different,
different psychoactive substances that exist in mushrooms.
So if you want it to get the exact effect of mushrooms,
you would have to make an artificial one,
right?
Wouldn't be as simple as just a suicide,
but you would have to have it in the exact,
the way it interacts with the silicon and the weather.
They interacts with a bunch of different shit inside of it.
It's not,
it's not just one thing.
Yeah,
I think
it's synthetic pot and stuff like that.
And it opens up certain things in your brain that makes you see things and you
can consider that as like,
like that's like a religion.
That's a guy that cause your,
your bodies,
you know,
your brain's reacting to this drug and you can even do it synthetically or you
can pick it off the ground.
So I think that that,
that,
that whole concept is probably like,
you know,
psychedelics might not be anything other than that.
Your brain reacting to something crazy up,
you know?
But if anything,
I think of what it's interesting that died.
If it does do something,
it's probably has something to do with just using parts of your brain that I
have never been used using it
before.
That to me is so fucking cool.
The fact that we use show little of our brain,
it's like,
wow,
how do we tap into the fucking arrest of it?
Yeah.
It doesn't have to be a god like what's fucking up here that we haven't even
fucking seen before?
Like that blow his mind.
Here's what we absolutely know.
We absolutely know that we exist in some sort of a state right here and right
now and that we know that this state,
this physical state,
that we all exist and we can experience it.
I,
you know,
I think therefore I am and you knock on wood,
it's right there when you have the psychedelic experiences,
what it may be doing in,
in,
you know,
it may may be doing by blasting your brain with all these thoughts and ideas.
It may be pushing evolution or pushing progress into a certain direction.
And that may be the very code of the universe itself.
That may very well be the idea of love and God is that exist in,
in promise.
It exists in potential in certain substances that interact with the brain in a
very positive way that makes life move forward in a positive direction.
So in a sense,
it is connecting you with God,
but in a sense that God doesn't really exist.
The God is an idea.
The God is,
is,
uh,
as a potential.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
It could easily be that.
It can easily be that there's something positive about it though.
And that's also why it's illegal.
That's why Charlie Sheen's girlfriend had to go down to Mexico to get that.
I begin cleaning itself up off that crack.
Uh,
yeah,
she was,
she was called a crack pipe recently.
She said it was a weed pipe,
but come on bitch and just smoke weed and then go get some Ibogaine treatment,
you know.
Sure.
Come clean.
She's going down to Mexico to get this,
uh,
this incredible psychedelic drug.
That's illegal in America has an incredible rate of curing addiction way better
than doctor drew.
Oh Wow.
I've been running into a lot of people lately that have been,
uh,
putting cocaine on weed lately.
Whoa.
Who the fuck you were hanging out with?
The strippers friends,
man.
He's an asshole and quiet dark rooms and,
no,
no.
These are people I've met at comedy clubs.
Really?
They're like,
hey man.
Yeah,
this is late.
Or a club.
Like audience members.
Yeah.
I know.
They've always told me,
but it's happened maybe twice.
I love that.
Hey,
you know this,
you know this weed that used to kind of open your mind and make you sort of more
creative and funny.
You want to add complete shaky paranoia to,
how about some fucking sweat night terrors,
the dripping sweat off Satan's ball sack race,
your joint with it.
I don't smoke weed that people is,
we try to get smoked weed and me,
I know a friend who was also a very famous fellow that got dosed
alright.
And he smokes and we with somebody and there was something in it that wasn't
weed and he was fucked up for like a day and a half.
So that's it.
I'm done.
Sorry.
I wish I good.
That happened to me when I,
when I was a kid I want to move.
Was it?
Ah,
ah,
so I either think it was crack or I think it was uh,
one of our,
one of our sober x dragging users tweeted when I described the story on the show
and they thought it was some kind of like a involvement in bombing tech smoke
shirt.
And I remember just like taking a hit with this shady kid on my porch and then
he was just like pretty cool about it.
He was like,
by the way,
man,
this may maybe late.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's why I feel like I'm going to die.
Mike.
And I knew,
yeah,
I didn't do read for
more I think than we think.
Like I think there's like these ghetto guys that are playing place,
they was like,
dude,
this shit's better than regular weed.
I put some balm and fluid on it.
Let's get Joe Rogan hot.
You know,
like I think it's like someone's just telling us that someone was trying to get
them high with her coked up joint.
Yeah,
it's,
it's more than we think because that it's happened to me twice in the last
month.
Think
about drugs like that is like,
so I like,
I stopped drinking and stuff cause I don't,
I don't do it well and a and having them,
just a few people do.
There's something bad,
biggest failure rate as far as people would do it.
Correct.
You know what I fucked in when I stopped drinking.
Literally a month later I started making a living as a comedian and I was like
so much.
You tell people that drinking is bad,
it has negative correlations.
Well,
it's terrible for your energy,
but it is great for having a good fucking Todd show what he wants to be that
Paul Newman and the hustler or he'd down bloodshot and makes that trick shot and
wins all the money in the bar and walks out.
I everybody wants to be that guy.
I could really handle his liquor.
So they're like Paul Newman if they're just so I can like hit his wife and just
like kind of a sad or Paul near event.
No,
they don't want that.
Paul Newman.
But he did grab Piper Laurie in that movie and Shaker,
which was really not alone.
Oh,
but I'll just say like,
so with the,
with the weed,
with the coke and weed,
like that's so interesting to me because someone is saying with their body like,
okay,
so I want to get high.
Right,
but that might make me too tired.
So then I got to balance it out and get coke.
And it's like,
so are you just smoking yourself back to normal?
It's like you were fucking fine.
You were literally,
you were that and now you're just doing that.
But it's addictive.
But my friend Johnny was a crackhead.
He actually died.
I mean,
he'd had a bunch of different things that used to do,
but he was my best friend in New York.
And he would,
he would always smoke crack and he'd tell me he'd smoke coke,
smoke crack,
like whatever he get.
And he would have to drink 40 ounces to calm himself down cause he would get to
the point where he was sweating and his heart was beating a hundred miles a
minute and he had a drink 40 ounces to denormalize them.
Right.
And you're just like,
well maybe if you know,
if he just didn't smell it because apparently the way it was explained to me by
my friend Steve,
who's an addiction specialist and he used to work and,
and try to work in treatment centers is you fire up that dopamine and you fire
up those levels when you do the coke and then your shit crashes and you're in.
It's such a depressed state that if you don't like fire it back up again
artificially.
You like feel terror and fucked up his,
I remember and a lot of people don't like know stuff like that because the at
five HTP,
well the first time you smoked crack apparently it's horrible.
It's fucking,
you just feel like the worst you've ever Fuckin felt yet you go back because
it's that addictive Brian Smoke crack.
It was just like doing cocaine.
Now,
me and my friend got back wreck
all of these fucking lame crack dealers out there.
Honestly,
it was just like,
oh yeah,
that was just like,
that was correct.
So I wanna I to switch gears before we end this thing because um,
there,
uh,
you're,
you're out here and you're,
I'm meeting with managers and you know Jamie Kilstein,
it's like one of these hot young comics.
It's like you can make a noise out there and there's a bunch of people looking
at you trying to see if they can make some money off him.
I watched this movie called overnight.
All right.
Do you ever seen overnight,
overnight is based on the guy who made the boondock saints?
I literally just had this conversation last night.
Have you seen it?
No,
but I got the full fucking synopsis from my friends from Derrick comedy the
other night.
Oh my God.
Somebody brought it up.
Somebody brought it up on the message board.
I just said,
I don't know where somebody had boondock saints as their,
um,
their screen name and they said something stupid that I didn't agree with.
So I just correlations correct.
So I just wrote boondock saints was a fucking terrible,
you know,
and then of course people were like,
well,
it's no zookeeper.
I'll dare you.
But she'll keep her head,
heart,
motherfucker.
Those animals are cute.
I'm talking.
So then this guy goes,
have you seen this documentary on the guy who made it?
And like,
I have the documentary,
I have it at home,
but it never bothered watching it.
But I pressed this youtube clip and I started watching it.
I said,
what the fuck?
Let me just see what this is all about.
That I'm hooked immediately hooked yet it is amazing.
It's a guy who,
well,
first of all,
his own friends made this documentary.
He was so full of himself that he thought that he was going to document this
rise to power at the boondock saints.
We all need to make that very clear.
The boondock saints were ever even made and no one knew how bad it was.
This guy was a bartender at this fucking place in Hollywood,
and he was like this tough guy from Boston smoking cigarettes talking about
shit.
And Harvey Weinstein bought his Weinstein.
Weinstein.
Whoever it is is a bad motherfucker.
You don't fuck with them.
I learned that from this movie.
So this guy starts talking mad shit.
He's gonna.
No one's ever been in a position like this before.
We get the number one fucking band,
the country,
the number one fucking movie.
It's in project work know.
So apparently all of his Braggadocia snus and cockiness and eventually turned
Harvey Weinstein off and he told me to go fuck himself and he canceled the
project.
Give me back some of my money.
Go it.
We're not making your movie.
And the document,
the movie,
the documentary details,
this guy who was like completely thought he was the shit on top of the world.
Treating people like,
you know,
he's a fucking like,
he's just the baddest motherfucker.
He's going to own Hollywood to everything falling apart to all these people
turning on him and him turning on them and was screaming in his band members.
Apparently.
That's what was so great
is first of all,
if anyone doesn't know what movies Harvey Weinstein has made,
it's all of them.
It is.
He made every movie that's ever made every mirror.
It's like one of those dudes like I'm not a movie buff.
I know I like movies,
but if you say Harvey Weinstein,
you,
Oh yeah,
well that guy's one of those bad motherfucker dude.
It's like he has,
he has a list somewhere of that blessed we were talking about,
he knows mercenaries.
That's who he is.
Oh,
for sure.
Actually.
And uh,
and so,
but what my friends were telling me is that what's so funny is so the friends
are making this documentary and he's a,
he's a cut to the friends too.
So as the movie progressed,
you slowly realize that the friends figure out what this movie is going to be
and now it's going to be about this guy's breakdown.
And apparently they just start kind of pushing them a little bit and just poking
a little bit and that they push him and poke him.
It seemed like he knew the cameras were rolling and he didn't have to do it.
That's to me,
what was the most spectacular thing about that level of self awareness?
I mean,
and we meet people like this every day,
whether it's they're just a cocky fighters,
are there other comics who were just terrible but socog and it's just like I,
I've never understood that mentality.
Like when you have that level of denial or,
or ego or nurses might block out everything,
a time move obsession.
It's an obsession with incorrect thinking,
right?
And this incorrect thinking is reinforced by all these people's adulation.
So you get really confused and you start thinking that's the correct way to
think.
And still you're smoking cigarettes,
talking about what a bad mother fucker you,
our boys were together were the brood and they're doing shots together and it's
just Douche baggery on a level that's like you cringe while you're watching your
toes curl up,
right?
Here's some of the things he says.
And he goes,
oh,
and also you,
you say,
if you say thank God it wasn't me who was in his situation because I might have
done the exact same thing and his time in his life with his life experiences
because people nowadays or it's like they don't think like entourage is as much
as I fucking television show or was it just like a something to strive to be,
you know what I mean?
Just to be that level of fucking famous and,
and the problem,
I think you're right about the hang around there,
there,
there was a,
there was a pretty famous comic who,
uh,
who I was doing the show without in Australia.
And it was the first time I saw a comic with an entourage.
And,
and,
and I don't think it was the entourage,
like doing shit for him,
but every interview,
so like before the taping of the show,
we all did like a little press around and we're like,
we'd go to each interview,
we're and just do an individual thing and you'd just do it by yourself and you
have to deal with a stupid fucking report or a new try to be like,
Huh.
And,
uh,
pretend you don't hate them.
And then you move on to the next guy and do the same thing.
And this dude with his entourage came and did the interviews with him and would
literally give him applause.
Brakes.
Whoa.
He's walked around and they were like,
Yay,
give up his name.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
well I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to use the names,
but if I was,
I would do it in the movie phone,
voice,
and then the Arnold Schwarzenegger voice.
And then my name would be Pablo Francisco [inaudible].
And,
uh,
and the weird thing was I talking to him backstage,
pretty nice,
you know,
like Super Nice.
But it's just like when you get to that level of,
he's crazy though.
You can't talk to him sometimes.
I love that guy,
but like we were outside of the company store ones and him and I were having a
conversation and went over to Brian and go,
you go talk to Pablo right now.
It's absolutely impossible.
Glove,
a conversation with them and he goes up going on over here at
this position.
And that's the thing is,
you know,
he,
he doesn't seem like a bad guy,
but was when you went,
when you get to that level,
when people just say,
hey man,
you're always funny.
Hey,
keep doing the voices.
And I'm almost like slowly like retards you back down to like,
you're almost like a kid if you're only,
you know,
I think the people that stay humble or the ones like,
I had a shitty life growing up.
I didn't have fucking a lot of friends.
I didn't have whatever.
So when you start to get things,
you really appreciate it,
you know what I mean?
And I think everyone needs that.
Everyone needs to work fucking retail once in their life or when he's talking
shit on,
everyone needs to go on a fucking road trip and break down.
I believe in Jujitsu.
That's also why I believe and I believe in,
in performing standup comedy,
that's also a thing at humble instantly Jujitsu.
Does martial arts do pull those?
I love the game pool because a ball either goes in or it doesn't go in.
It's,
it's very difficult to keep everything together and all on the stroking line.
That's what I love,
man.
You can be the typical dude and you have the top out in digits.
You can,
you know,
think you're a really funny guy and you go in front of that audience and then
you can try.
It doesn't work that instant.
Well,
especially if you,
if you don't respect them,
it's just like you don't respect an opponent.
You know you can get caught in an arm bar real quick.
If you don't respect an audience,
you don't respect their attention span.
Man.
They can get to a point where we're like,
we don't like you.
And I'm like,
Shit,
I thought you liked me and I like to couple of minutes ago when you started off
pretty funny,
but now we don't like anymore.
Yeah man.
That's feel after every joke is like time started down start again and it's real
and every time you throw out a fucking special you do,
you do a special old,
that's an hour that's gone.
Now it's time for a whole new hour.
You better have evolved.
Was that the last question you think there is,
but it's just forcing yourself into a situation.
Louis C K is the best example of that and he,
you know,
the way he described it was really kind of cool.
He said if you tomorrow,
uh,
we're going to,
you couldn't use your material anymore.
You just had to stop.
Would you just stop doing comedy if you could not use it?
It was absolutely impossible.
For whatever reason,
whatever stupid reason,
I'm already know you wouldn't stop doing comedy.
You would just come up with new jokes.
You said that and I started thinking of another like premise and like a panic.
I'm just like,
why would I write about,
that's,
that's the pot lace coke have entertained the,
the,
the humility though is a huge factor.
But in Hollywood,
humility is,
um,
it's,
it's one of the weird,
sort of a breeding ground for,
for Hubris and even in,
in,
and cockiness and people who are just really delusional man,
because it's world of make believe because it's a world where the bad mother
Fucker,
all he has to do is be able to pretend he's a bad motherfucker when the cameras
are on.
It's not a real bad motherfucker.
It's a guy who,
there's writers and they've spent weeks formulating his dialogue,
do the absolute perfect economy of words,
and the music comes on when he's on screen and he gets all of that adulation.
It starts thinking he's the shit.
And it's,
it's the same thing with this,
this guy who was in this movie.
It's the same thing with anybody that's a narcissist or anybody that's over the
top.
And then we feed into it.
You know,
it's like there was,
um,
there was this,
uh,
whenever,
when we were,
when we were younger,
uh,
I'm a Hawaiian,
right?
And so would you stay?
We were poor,
but we'd go to Hawaii to see family and stuff and a lot of times we would sneak
into these fancy hotels and this is 100% sure what you're sticking to these like
fancy hotels and just kind of Beverly hillbilly it and say,
my dad was checking in and then would go like swimming pools and shit and a,
you got to these places,
man,
and you stay there for long enough and you're like,
uh,
the,
they get what everyone gets whatever they want,
right?
No one's necessarily a dick about it.
They're just used to getting whatever they want.
There's,
there's no danger around,
there's nothing to worry about.
And then you leave that area and then you see like for the first time,
no matter how good of a person you are and about how empathetic you are,
you see like a homeless person,
you and your first reaction is like,
what the fuck is that?
Because you're just,
you're not used to it.
You know what I mean?
We're in the resort and you're just surrounded by comfort.
Um,
and does that make you a bad person?
No,
but I,
I,
you know what the one thing Obama did say that I really fucking like before,
uh,
I voted for him and he destroyed everything that,
I believe then,
uh,
was he said,
we have this country has an empathy deficit disorder.
Right.
And it's like a little play on words,
but,
uh,
but I think that's really true.
Like I didn't start to have empathy until I started to travel.
And I remember when fucking prevents it brought me to China to open from when I
was younger and still like living out of my car.
I got to China,
my first thought was,
I didn't know this was a real place.
Like obviously like I wasn't an idiot.
Like,
I didn't just think of it like a spot,
but to me it was just like,
I knew what the shape of the map when I'd see the new stories,
but that's why you can watch,
you know,
you'll be watching day three of the earthquake in Japan footage and you're kind
of like,
there'll be part of you.
And I hate saying this,
that's like,
all right,
I get it.
There's a fucking earthquake.
Because like you've never,
you don't know how bad that shit is.
And once you see places,
once you meet people from other places,
I remember we did it.
I did a show in Oklahoma City and like there's a murder in Oklahoma city a
couple months later.
And my first I was,
oh my God,
I know a person there.
And I'm like,
I would've just blown off that fucking story otherwise.
And like I think you just have to,
every time you're like,
oh,
why doesn't that fucking person get a job?
Just think about like,
if you don't have kids,
if you don't have a job,
how fucking scary it is to wake up every fucking morning.
Be like,
do I look for a job?
Do I take care of my kids?
Do I pull my kid out of school to watch?
I mean,
there's so much shit that you just have to just shut the fuck up and just think
about what it's like to be that person.
I mean,
that's really what I think it comes down to you for just being like decent.
You just have to have fucking empathy.
That's it.
It's definitely easy to lose your perspective if you're in a resort all the
time.
Or if you're some Hollywood douche bag that got handed a half a million dollars
from some huge production company to make your first film and you really start
believing you are the shit.
Even though had people talk to me this week,
I'm just like,
that's not a real sense.
You don't believe when you're on,
you're in the grooming stage,
you're in,
you're in the stage where people are looking at you and they're,
you know,
they're courting you.
Yeah.
You know,
they're trying to see if they could make some money out for you.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean like,
yeah.
It's one of those things where it's like,
I feel like we were talking about like what's selling out is,
and I think that I think that as long as you're saying what you want to say,
if you know,
if I make $1 billion going after these fucking giant corporations and uh,
you know,
not compromising and attacking the Democrats and Republican,
like I deserve that billion dollars.
[inaudible] how are you going to make the billion dollars though?
You
know what I'm saying?
I mean,
in the most hypothetical situations,
the show so far,
it's what are you doing?
You know,
if you're doing something you don't like,
you know what the biggest,
the feeling of selling out for me ever was,
was doing a bad sitcom.
When I did a hardball,
I had never been more miserable performing work then performing a bad sitcom.
It was,
it's when you're reading shit that you know is really bad and the audience is
not laughing and you're forced to do it over and over again and you know it's
going to be on TV.
That's when you're like,
wow,
this is unfulfilling and has nothing to do with the CIC common.
It was the fact that creatively it was a bad sick.
I'm newsradio funny fucking set comp.
Yeah,
well I got really fortunate and I went from worse possible scenario to best
possible scenario in a row.
But what it made me think was like,
okay this ride,
it's too fucking crazy.
I want to get off like the Sitcom ride.
It's like you're either feast or famine.
You either have brilliant writing or you have dog shit.
And I did some guest spots on some shows that weren't so hot and I,
you know,
read some scripts that weren't so hot.
It's like there's a lot of lot of bad shit out there.
Previews on TV I saw pretty good for the uh,
the one where like fucking end,
Jason Bateman and Green Lantern Piss into a fountain and then they change
because one's a family man.
I'm one.
Oh yeah.
What the fuck is that?
And it's literally someone walked in.
It's the exact same plot of all these other movies.
But the twist is like the pest in a fountain and it shows you,
I will show was you and you see that movie.
Have you seen that ad
that's making fun of itself.
It's like a hot tub time machine now that's the whole point they're taking.
That's kind of what it is though.
It doesn't look funny enough to,
to for them to take credit for that.
But what I was gonna say,
so I mean take any fucking bad movie example.
Right?
What's so funny?
So you look at it and your first thought is that looks like a shitty movie,
but then you think about how much money was spent.
Someone wrote it,
someone wrote a first draft and was like pissed it a fountain.
You know the movie that I just did,
man,
there's fucking talking animals.
You know,
there's no reason why they talk and there's a code.
They're not supposed to talk in a differences.
It's a kid's movie.
You know the kids might be is really,
it is ridiculous.
The idea that you can fucking just sell the fact that what no rock came from
outer space.
Now all sudden they can talk.
No,
they just always talk.
Someone pitched it to someone that someone went through,
someone edited it,
some Wa,
you know what I mean?
Like they pissed in a fountain.
They shouldn't be.
There shouldn't be a scene where after they pitched it and found one of them
goes,
what's we pissed in the fountain and now we switched roles.
That's the dumbest fucking thing I've ever heard in my life.
They do what the movie's about.
It actually says it like that.
Actually I get looks good.
I'm going to get,
you're trying to trick us.
By the way,
he's famous for not researching things.
You'll not going on Google right now looking for the quotes.
I think even in the trailer they say like it's a
stupid joke.
There's movies man,
where you just see the movie and you go,
I wish I was there while they were making this like showgirls.
That must've been a cocaine rampage movie.
People got rejected from that.
When people auditioned and people audition and then we're like,
oh,
I didn't get into fucking showgirls.
Like I mean like there was so much.
But then conversely,
the good news is then every once in a while something like the wire gets made or
something.
Yeah.
And those pitch meetings to me or even more,
it makes more sense to me that whoever made the zookeeper can walk in and be
like talking to animals,
Kevin James Redundant.
They're like,
here's a million or $1 billion.
And then they let them use the monkey.
Yeah,
it makes less sense to me that someone fucking pitch to Wally.
Right?
Someone went in there and was like,
all right,
so it's going to be anti corporation is going to be pro environment.
Here's the twist.
No fucking dialogue for like the first hour.
It's just a fucking robot.
But you can tell his personality through his eyes and someone was like,
all right,
we'll do it,
or the,
or.
Let's make a show that actually makes drug dealers a complex and makes cops are
bad sometimes.
And here's the twist,
not that many gunfights and it makes violence look disgusting.
Someone fucking took a chance and made it,
you know what I mean?
So cool.
Shit's still can't happen,
but as sort of seems to happen,
if nobody fucks with it,
that's the,
that's really the thing I was,
I lose some shows are good.
Yeah.
Perfect example.
It,
it has to come from an individual point of view.
You know,
when I was talking to Anthony Bordain,
if you've ever watched the show notes,
I know,
I know the show that show,
this is a show that Mark Marin tried to cock block me on.
But uh,
it's a brilliant show.
But one of the more brilliant aspects of it is that it comes from an individual
point of view.
It comes from one man who has a passion in view of,
of food and of the world and of exploring all these different cultures.
And it comes from him.
He's narrating in,
he's writing things down and that that is missing,
man,
that you,
that individual unique point of view.
And there's far too many times where any project gets started.
And too many fucking people have a vision of how this thing should be.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Your audience may,
it may,
this may get a little cheesy.
I'll,
I'll be really need to tell you this.
One of the funniest thing.
So we were having trouble getting in touch this weekend.
Could you were away and I was traveling.
We were both traveling and uh,
I remember I was like,
I'm not really sure if I'm doing the show.
And then yesterday suddenly I got like 200 new Twitter followers and I go to
check my mail on.
The first one I see is legalized weed is now following you.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm doing Joe's podcast.
Uh,
but uh,
but w w what's really,
what the fuck are we talking about?
God dammit.
Um,
we the the Oh yeah,
the,
yeah,
the single person being in charge.
Um,
what's,
what's now called,
I forgot
Cecil B demented.
Have you ever seen it?
Check out?
This is an old school movie from the past where the projectionists of this movie
theater got so tired of like Hollywood movies and stuff like that.
So they ended up like kidnapping,
like everyone and making their whole movie.
It's pretty,
it's a John Waters Film.
It's pretty out there.
But it's kind of like about the,
you know,
the old independent,
one person's vision or at least,
you know,
well,
I've seen it in when we try to do the man show,
you know,
when you have too many people from networks and you know,
if too many people from the production side of it trying to give their own
opinion,
change things,
it's,
it's very hard to get an individual like,
like what South Park does because they're so successful.
And these and these and these motherfuckers too.
Like you're doing a standup special and you have someone trying to edit you
right in charge of content and someone's pitching you,
you know,
instead of saying pussy say this,
it's not another fucking comic.
Is that you?
It's a goddamn lawyer.
Right.
It's a fucking lawyer.
They don't about comedy.
They don't anything about jokes.
But I was going to say,
uh,
before is that I feel like with stand up,
especially the edgiest thing you can do nowadays,
you know,
people do think you're edgy by,
by,
by dropping the fucking and word or by,
or we're using the faggot.
Are we making a rape jokes or whatever.
The edgiest thing you can do is be fucking honest.
You know what I mean?
Do you,
I just think I think you can do is be like vulnerable.
You can do all those things,
but like you watch these old comics,
none of them will ever fucking tell them about like a fear they have or sometime
they fight.
It's all this fucking detached sort of like,
oh well look,
I have a chart.
So that makes me different because I'm the guy with charts and it's just like,
just fucking who are you?
You know what I mean?
Just stays on me fucking honest.
And I,
I really do think nowadays that's the edgiest thing you can do is just be on,
have your own fucking point of view.
How'd that come from a Twitter follower thing where you get there?
Oh,
the Twitter follower thing.
I think I had a long time ago and then a pop that
it came from.
I know you tried to see the trail.
It came from boarding.
I think it came from Brew Day in and just when you were saying having your own
point of view and I'm like that is a lot rarer and comedy than it should be
because that's what companies should be.
It's hard to really have an individual point of view,
you know?
I mean you have to really fucking think things through and you have to have some
personal sovereignty.
There's three still.
I always say in my opinion there are three steps to comedy.
Step one is when you first started now and then you do whatever you think works
terrifying to be onstage bomb half the time I tried to be Jim Norton.
Did you really?
Yeah,
I used to listen to opie and Anthony a lot and uh,
I was just like so and now what?
Talking about rape and anything with Jim,
what I didn't realize about Jim that makes him so good is Jim's not after gym.
All of the,
especially cause I was in New York,
all of the people who want it to be like Jim Norton would just be like blah,
blah,
blah.
The prostitute was in my car.
And like that's,
you know,
that's kind of the punchline was like I fucking killed her.
And it's like,
all right.
But what's so cool about Jim is Jim was doing that on his vulnerable thing that
we were just talking about where he was saying like,
no,
this is a fucking problem.
And that's what made it so different.
It's this was his addiction.
This was something that he couldn't fucking stop.
And then he was filthy and funny on top of it.
But that's the difference is it was something personal on top of the fucking
filth.
And that's what made it so interesting.
So I think the first step is you just trying to say anything that will get a
reaction from the audience.
Right?
And then step two,
once you get a little better,
he started saying things that you actually think are funny.
Things that actually make you laugh.
And then step three is when you get into the black gold shit,
that's when you start making fun of you start the concepts and ideas and you
start bringing philosophy into the,
into the picture and you start having weird points of view that you figured out
a way to make funny,
you know,
and then you can introduce ideas into people's minds.
Like when you said very good point earlier that conservatives can come up to you
after a show and say,
I didn't agree with you but you made me laugh.
Right?
But that's one of the most important things about being a standup comic is you
can introduce it and idea into the mind of someone who might not necessarily
have ever considered that before.
Just by doing it in a way that makes them laugh.
Because if you say something,
you get onstage and you say,
I believe Blah,
blah,
someone in the audience is going to go,
well,
I kind of disagree.
I think this and that.
And you know we have an,
I have a point of view too,
but if you say something and you make them laugh,
then they go,
ha,
and I'll agree with you,
but you're a fucking though.
It was pretty fun.
I got to consider it's the Machita kick.
You're just suddenly like,
what the fuck was that?
Oh yeah,
no,
we're cool.
It's fine.
Anyone of them.
A Cheetah kick is some fucking karate kid.
Bullshit all comes around,
man.
Now I was,
the only thing that saved me from this whole Steven Seagal bullshit is I'm like,
if junior dos Santos hits a fucking jump kick a hot bed,
I'm like,
all right.
It's like all,
you know what I mean?
Like Mochida all right,
fine.
But I'm like,
if junior who I've never,
I don't even know if he like kicks.
I was just like,
if he starts to jump kick [inaudible] to his arsenal,
for sure he will,
but he doesn't.
I don't think he's training with those guys anymore.
Junior moved.
See,
that's the other thing that's weird about Jamie Kilstein.
He's a lefty,
but he's a mixed martial arts fanatic.
Love is a Vegan,
but he likes cage fighting.
How the fuck do you reconcile those things?
Well,
there's different,
I was telling,
I said,
I was telling Ron this weekend that I was saying that,
uh,
you know,
one of my friends was like,
I want to go to a UFC event.
You think I'm gonna get into a fight?
And uh,
and I go,
the people you don't have to worry about are the big fucking dude screaming the
ones in the tap out shirts.
They're fine.
If you see a kid by himself reading a book with a Hoodie,
that kids that Hugh Jitsu,
he will fucking kill.
You see a little skinny guy with some fucked up ears,
stay away from him.
My brother has cauliflower ear and these two fuckers tried to start a fire with
him at a bar and he's really chill and it just kind of like,
you don't want to do that.
Like he's a,
he's a division one wrestler and like is like with Ricardo and made his team now
and,
and they were just like,
you fucking pussy was every cliche bar thing.
And then one of the guys literally just stared at his ears and just like stops
is that the French just like shut the fuck up,
shut the fuck up.
And then they just walked away like the cauliflower ear.
Man,
that's fun.
I'll look for that man can call me float you for the most part,
he's probably wrestling a lot more than you are my friend.
This get dominant Darcus uh,
he was a hilarious Improv guy from UCB.
We were talking about that yesterday because he doesn't get to two and a,
he was like,
even if the guy's not a wrestler,
that means something else fucking dark end.
That means he took a fucking brick to the year or like he still does something
fucked up where that happens,
especially if they're both Jack's high now when you get the real fat one,
like have you ever seen what lean Ishmael and the leg,
they call him,
he's,
he's fucking ears.
It looks like a mouse with like a bullet hole in it.
That's what his ear looks like.
It doesn't even look like it's a real ear.
It's so fucking fat and there's no,
you know,
this whole design of the ear,
there's a reason for all that.
The sound comes in and it echoes off of that and it's,
it's,
you know,
it enhances everything.
He gets none of that shit.
He has a hole in the hole and this is big clump of,
of clotting.
Jesus is leading and hardening.
Ah,
they should be able to just chop it off,
throw a new year,
you know,
they can fix it.
They,
my,
my friend Brent had his fixed,
he,
uh,
he got too bad.
So they slice off the ear,
they pull it back,
they cut all the,
the,
the scar tissue and all the shit out and they put it back together and it looks
reasonably good,
but it has real problems with some guys.
Dave terrail started getting some serious infections were,
uh,
his ears.
They had to take his ears off and then they had a quarter rocks.
Yeah.
Cauterize inside his ear.
So you man,
that's why your guards bro.
Oh fuck.
With that regards.
That's why I don't worship God.
I will fucking a warship science when they're like,
might you rehearse like,
oh,
I'm just gonna take it off.
Going to pull the shit through fucked.
He's been fucked for over a year for this.
She spins.
It's really,
it's a really bad situation.
Yeah.
It kept him from fighting.
He's had a bunch of different operations.
She's the worst I've ever heard.
But soccer,
rob a lost is a year and a flight and you see that [inaudible] mom's keys hit
him and it's fucking ear.
Like literally it was hanging off.
Yeah,
but that's because the zero is like a brick.
It's like there's a hard ass fucking piece of rock attached to the skin in
Sakharova.
Man.
He's a guy that's been around for the longest time.
Yeah,
I'd Hey,
did you see the leave in Munios got assigned for today?
Yeah.
That's going to be in the UK that you can't,
people are pissed off about that fight.
It took us a couple of pillar fun eyesight and killer fucking fly.
A bunch of wine is obese.
Shit.
He caught of the hand the you came eight.
That's a great fight.
And who knows what the undercard is going to be,
but I guarantee it's going to be great to the,
uh,
they try to make those UK fights is,
is exciting as possible.
That's a good fight to me.
She's a fucking killer and sick wrestler and,
and it's a monster now,
especially coming off that Vandelay Silva knockout like man,
never still was the leap Akiyama where it's like,
fuck you.
It's the biggest fucking messy,
sloppy SLAAC fast.
And then it ends in a perfect triangle.
Managing [inaudible] actually got to the point where he could rechallenge
Anderson Silva and if he actually made a fucking flight out of it.
Yeah.
You know,
wild.
That would be,
man,
he never fucking know.
I mean,
I would imagine that if you watched that first fight,
the way he charged out after Anderson Silva,
I would imagine if you put the two of them,
the octagon again,
he would never do it that way.
I'm sorry there.
We never fight that way again.
That said,
Anderson is the most accurate guy that's ever fought.
I mean,
he's a,
he's a fucking assassin.
If there's openings,
he takes him,
you're fucked,
you get lit up.
I show any,
any of my fucking friends are fans who were like,
oh,
I'm really like boxing.
You know,
you show him both Don Frye staff and they can turn and be like,
oh,
the sweet science is for,
I just had the guy's neck just punch,
punch,
punch.
But you show him that Anderson Silva Forest Shit.
And,
and I mean every,
you show it to anybody who doesn't know anything about fighting and they're
like,
oh,
that looks like a movie.
The Lieben fights the best example for me because that's what happens when a guy
who's just wild and aggressive comes charging after guy who just going to call
assassin.
Yeah.
He's in the Matrix and he just nails him with everything.
It doesn't get hit with anything.
Nails done with everything.
Super accurate.
And he does it with clinical precision.
Yep.
You know,
I'm,
I'm very excited to see that.
I would love to see leaving versus a lot of guys right now.
We've been after that Vandelay Silva knockout leap bins on fucking fire.
I mean you gotta think he stumbled in the Brian Stann fight.
I give him a pass on that cause I knew he was sick.
And Brian's stands up beast.
Anyway.
I'm sure you know Brian Stann can fuck you up dude.
If you get hit by Brian Stann,
Brian's stamped fucked up Santiago.
You know who?
Fuck up a lot of guys,
man.
These people are sleeping on stand on his rights.
Pretty Fun guy.
Brian.
Stan was in the shit.
Okay.
He was over there with bullets flying through the air and smashing into people's
heads near him that,
you know what I'm saying?
When you've been through that a regular fight,
like an MMA fight,
it takes on a totally different,
it's a totally different experience.
It's got to seem pretty easy.
It's like,
Hey,
you know what?
You can't do call on your friends to bomb me.
Yeah,
he can.
he's him and Tim Kennedy's a few of those guys like Tim Kennedy,
special Kennedy.
I heard the Fuckin at one really good guy and I love his fucking Jujitsu.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's for everything is standup's good.
His jujitsu's could.
But those guys mean you don't go from that environment,
you know,
to,
to cage fighting.
It's gotta be pretty easy.
It's a pretty easy transition theory,
man.
The chairlift fights interesting though,
because,
uh,
because it's jail channels a beast.
Yeah.
He's a serious wrestling and take away all his shit talking,
which is monumental.
He's the greatest shit talker that's ever existed.
That newest one was crazy with Ariel or with the Nogueira brothers when I was
gonna say I have about Anderson,
but he was,
he,
you think he beat me when a guy's beating your ass for four and a half minutes
and you wrap your legs around his head for eight seconds,
you think you won.
And what's so funny is you see that and you start laughing and you're like,
yeah,
fucking jail,
God.
Him.
And then you press stop and you're like,
oh yeah,
no,
he did one.
That's exactly what happened is he got you to tap out.
He's brilliant though.
It's not,
it's not based in reality.
It's just based in fucking theatrical.
It's the asics are incredible.
But I love about Anderson.
What's so cool about the UFC right now?
I,
the reason I think it's the most excited and it's ever been,
it's because you look at it,
a lot of the champion,
she looked at a lot of the people who have the most hype and they're doing the
craziest shit out there.
They're riskier shit.
Fucking John Jones.
You have Anderson,
you have Dominick Cruz,
you're half a Anthony Pettis got people were bad.
Hundreds.
I mean you have people who are just doing such new innovative.
Yeah.
I mean that Carlos Condit fight man.
We just had him on the fucking show,
the full set of wine.
He was great.
Ah,
but cooler than the fucking flat.
That butterfly sweep needs to be talked about more.
Fuck yeah.
That was the cause that he was in a truck,
but that was the one place where it's like,
oh,
he's going to get light on him as a serious judo guy.
Yeah.
You're just like,
he's just going,
he's about to get sucked up now for the entire route.
He's against smaller team over easy mount and then trying for the gala.
200 is a beast.
Conduit is a fucking beast.
He's right there in the hunt.
Look,
Jamie Kilstein,
you've got a car outside waiting to take you to the God damn air patio.
So,
uh,
thank you very much for being on the podcast.
Follow Jamie on Twitter at Jamie Kilstein as j a m I e K.
I l s t e I n and follow him on Twitter and check out citizen radio.
You can um,
we're,
we're can they get citizen?
We are citizen radio.com or just iTunes under citizen,
right in their iTunes under citizen radio.
And of course your chops.
He and Carlos Condit,
that's,
he makes his shit up
bitch.
And um,
oh that's it.
This weekend at the Ice House in Pasadena.
It's a small club.
That shit will sell out quick.
So dive on that hookers and I'm Brian red bands can get drunk and go on stage,
right Brian?
Yeah,
I'll be there Thursday to Thursday too.
Powerful
Thursday.
Uh,
we will be back several times this week,
probably tomorrow.
And then Sunday me and Michael Chavela,
we're going to do a fucking Solo podcast out of me house.
So you don't have to be there for that one.
It's gotta to be all MMA and hookers and cock punches.
All right,
so this weekend we put,
I put up a bunch of new things to,
uh,
Milwaukee's coming up August 13th,
I think,
and some other shit going down.
Listen.
Hey,
checkout this flashlight has a new movie out called flash lighting.
It's hilarious.
It's how I got Jenna haze on it.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's hilarious.
Like a fake movie previews.
You laugh.
I,
yeah,
I thought it was ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
It's just pissing the fountain.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Wow.
We thank the flashlight for sponsoring the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for man.
Oh.
And then you could shoot Mosan in it.
You'll feel better about life.
I love all of you and I thank you very much.
And we're going to figure out this hum and you won't have to listen to it next
time.
I apologize.
Just Jamie had to go back to New York.
We had a did it.
We had to do it this way.
Thank you all.
Love you.
Bye Bye.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.